um or does anybody know this
so to consist of a quorum for an
executive session we clearly have enough
people here to have a hearing but if we
don't have a single member of the
democratic caucus in attendance how does
this
clerk all right itl just
[Laughter]
motion
e
morning we are
re well first let's start uh if you
wouldn't mind joining me for the Pledge
of
Allegiance I pledge of algi to the flag
United
States the rep for it stands one
na
indivisible did you open the hearing the
exec what did you open this
I just okay we are back in house bill
1012 executive session and I recognize
representative Reed to make a
motion thank you Mr chairman I um motion
1012 um I make an OTP motion on House
FN would you like to speak to your
motion um I would I like this this bill
because um Everybody every parent knows
their child and um everybody has
different opinions of what is safe and
not safe for a child to do and I think
this bill protects parents um choice in
what they allowed their their children
to safely do I see this is a a nice
protection thank you thank you
representa tenar would you like to speak
to a second I just like to say concur
with representative re and well said
Thank You
discussion represent Murray thank you Mr
chair um I have some concerns with this
bill in terms of just creating a blanket
exception um that doesn't really seem
necessary in my opinion I did try to
work with the sponsor on an amendment to
address the concerns that were raised by
attorney Enders and new Futures and she
was not willing to make the changes we
discussed um and so because of that I
will be voting against this bill and I
would urge others to do the
discussion can you can you clarify there
are guidelines guard rails in here to
protect the the child um if a parent can
present their R rationale for allowing a
child to to do a certain activity um I
mean there's common sense built into
well the specific point that attorney
Enders raised was I think it was um I
don't have the text of the bill in front
of me if you give me just one second but
um that it said parents uh can't be um
you know charged I guess uh if uh no
actual harm was done to the child and in
attorney Ender's opinion and in mine um
you know usually we we want to stop har
before it happens and not wait until a
PR so I know I may be older than dirt
but um this is kind of like how I grew
up um I had to be home when the street
lights came on nobody was helicoptering
over me making sure
everything was okay we used to run
around in the woods and all kinds of
stuff so I I think just just let's
parents go back to that because
somewhere along the
way we' have decided that our children
cannot do anything unless we're two feet
away from them watching them um they
don't get any life
experiences um you know you got to
scrape your knees a few times and to
figure out to do that so if you don't
have these life experiences growing up
then you won't be ready for real life
18 thank you my concern is that a bill
that says uh it it's actually creating
uh an exemption that encourages uh uh
Freedom uh in children um
actually seems like it it has the
potential to actually put kids into more
danger and I think the reason for that
is is the bill really doesn't specify
what types of endangerment activities
would be covered under the law so I I
know the sponsor's intent was to create
a bill that uh addressed what she thinks
is is an overly broad statute but I
think the way to address a statute that
you think is overly broad isn't by
replacing it with another statute that
it's equally
you representative Reed um there's been
an amendment proposed to this bill um by
the sponsor um and it makes a change to
the last sentence if if you wouldn't
mind represent Murray Could you please
call out the difference in in the
amendment um thank you Mr chair from
comparing the text um the only
difference I see is the added lines of
13 and 14 which adds a new section that
says it is not a violation of the
section for parents to allow children to
take reasonable risks to further their
development as independent human beings
thank
you
um no I I'm about to pass it out um
could you pass that to the left and
right hasn't been introduced yet I'm
going to ask um if representative Reed
would withdraw her OTP motion and then
uh make an OT uh introduce the amendment
um if that would be okay do you withdraw
yes I you withdraw your
second um the amendment's coming around
we know that it's just a one change uh
second excuse me one sentence change
that I
believe
um that she made after
conferring with several people I think
sure
now that you have it if you if you could
just look at um the addition is
end
so I recognize representative Reed to
make a
motion I motion to um ought to pass on
054h second representative tzar um we're
still in basically the same discussion
um anyone have anything further to add
um based on the the one sentence
otherwise representative Reed um I still
believe that um life is dangerous
there's no guarantee that any of our
activities are not going to end in us
getting hurt falling down the stairs cut
in a bagel all of those things can be
dangerous I think that parents um we
should give them credit for common sense
and knowing their children and I think
it's better for child development for
them to be able to be kids than to have
um constant fear of getting hurt and
being hovered over and I think this bill
is long overdue and we should pass it
thank you represent Murray thank you Mr
chair I feel like people are thinking of
like a specific set of circumstances
with the spill I have no problem with
kids running around outside and I did
that as well when I was a kid and as far
as I understand that's not currently
outlawed um but the guidelines here are
just so broad um and it mentions actual
injury or harm that doesn't um account
for any potential mental or emotional
distress that may happen to a child due
to uh parental decisions or parental
neglect um
I um just to share some of my own
experience grew up um going to a church
that my parents were um unfortunately
manipulated into because of their own
circumstances um growing up and fears
they had about me being out in the world
and in that church
um many of the kids were not allowed to
get to know any other kids their own age
we were all
homeschooled um we were not allowed to
engage with the world in a way that is
necessary for kids growing up and I just
don't think this is taking into account
like according to this you know this
feels like it would leave an exception
for parents who want to just like keep
their kid in the house all day long all
year round and never seeing other human
being that would be allowed with this
bill and it's there's just no account
for the like mental and emotional
well-being of these kids um and I I just
feel like again the guidelines are just
so
broad um I just don't understand why we
need to make an exemption when we
already have laws that make clear what's
a crime and what's not a
crime thank you just for the record um I
was kept inside my entire childood look
how I turned out um representative Lynn
I would like to invite you to give us a
class everyone hearken and listen to the
former Supreme Court Justice on a a
class of statutory construction could
you tell us please when you have a
colon after an offense under this
section if then we have a b c and d what
do the colons or semicolons mean after
each sentence ABC and because at
sentence c i noticed colon and and so
I'm reading the other semicolons to read
or I
Beal okay so just for clarification no
parent or legal guardian of a child who
makes a parenting decision shall be
guilty of an offense under this section
if a there's no actual injury or harm
and no actual injury or harm is the
result of an unavoidable or unforeseen
accident would if that section A is not
satisfied does then the rest not matter
it's irrelevant think in order to this
to invoke this section I think you have
to satisfy all all four so I mean the so
forg there was no actual injury of har
um you you wouldn't satisfy this section
mean the whole class sorry about that if
you uh if you didn't satisfy let's say a
Your example then you wouldn't satisfy
this section that I don't think that
necessarily means that what you've done
is a crime there may you may not you
know you may not satisfy the the all of
the sections of whatever whatever
provision um would make it a crime but
you wouldn't satisfy this unless you met
all four of them so I I guess here's a
question I'm trying to get an example
for example uh so
um there's a reasoned approach let's go
to C to such a decisionmaking that takes
into consideration risk versus benefit
if I did decide to keep my child
sequestered never let them out would I
then not get the protections of this
because there's really not a reason to
approach to do such a thing or would I
still be protected because there was no
injury proven to the child because I
kept them locked up
inside right I mean well I mean if there
was you know if I I think harm doesn't
necessarily mean physical harm only if
there was emotional or you know harm
that kind of thing I think that could
that could be harm so a child left alone
for example who who was traumatized by
that they could still be charged with
neglect because of the first sentence a
right I mean if the other right exactly
yes yeah yeah no I think that's right I
right yes all right so in my opinion if
someone does something so irresponsible
with their child that it it results in
emotional harm uh physical harm or or um
even if it's just potential physical
danger but still gives them emotional
trauma and that's picked up at either at
school or however it's a doctor they can
still be charged with neglect because of
that word harm um so I think that
answers a lot of of the questions we've
heard um it doesn't maybe not satisfying
to everybody but I just wanted to point
it out further discussion um
representative s and then Bal thank you
um I oppose the the underlying bill as
well as the amendment because to me it
it feels hypocritical if we're not
allowing parents to make medical
decisions for their children based on
their children's needs which we've
blocked as a house then then it seems to
me that this bill is also so unnecessary
and so it it just feels like a
hypocritical we want to have our cake an
eat it too and I don't think that's
Bolton I I really want to push back
really hard against the idea that it's
possible to prove emotional or
psychological harm um I'm not aware of
any cases in the family court system
where that's been proven therapists are
uh they typically will require um during
the
um the process of uh you know setting up
a new patient file that'll require
signing a contract that says you won't
make the therapist go to court um the uh
judges in new Hamp there's a bill I
think in child and family right now
where they're or I think we I don't
remember if it got voted on yesterday
but where they're sort of begging judges
to allow to give more consideration to
the views of the children it's
extraordinarily difficult ult to bring
in any kind of testimony from a mental
health expert on psychological or
emotional harm and I don't it seems like
this
would set it up so
that someone who is causing that because
it's so difficult to prove that they're
causing that would get off scot-free and
I'm and I and I can't stress enough the
immense difficulty in proving
psychological or emotional harm but I
don't know if maybe representative Lynn
wants to speak I don't know if he's if
he was ever in the Family Court thank
you I I would suggest that you probably
are correct but you are missing the
point that we're talking about a
criminal statute which would be the
neglect statute so the contract is
irrelevant um it could be brought in um
the testimony and the the um all the
evidence could be brought in because the
criminal statute would Trump that in a
civil case I agree if it was a custody
case or something like that it's very
difficult but a criminal case that
evidence would be allowed just uh
justice ly representative Lynn would you
like to speak to
that well I I I I guess I would say that
um I I think I agree that it is
difficult to prove emotional harm or it
often can be particularly in the context
of you know if this if you had a Mal if
you had some kind of a malpractice case
or or uh a case that was sort of
specifically focused on that and there
was time to get experts and all that
maybe it's maybe it's not as difficult
but I think I agree with you in the
context of of of a criminal case is
probably you know that that that
probably is true um you know I guess
when when um I believe was this this was
representative was this representative
leakas bill or kushman kushman I'm sorry
repr I what somebody spoke to me about
this bill and one of the things that I
said the reason that I thought it was
that something like this I'm not
particularly married to any specific
language but something like this was
important is it just seemed to
me it did make sense to have something
in the law to say that the legislature
recognizes or the law recognizes
that we can go too far in trying to
protect protect children and really end
up harming them because you you you
restrict them so so much that they don't
have a chance to live and and I think
it's it's important to have something in
the law just to say that the specifics
of exactly how it's worded I think this
I personally think this is fine but you
know it doesn't have to be this I just
think having something that says it's
okay for parents to let their kids take
risks is a is an important thing to to
say
thank you um just I I've did some
research myself and eight other states
have passed laws like this that they've
gained the moniker of free range free
range parenting I believe um I see you
represent Jamon
chairman I don't I see this bill as a
totally different in a totally different
way um as somebody that grew up with um
their parents absent and grew up my
she she allowed me to do a lot of things
that normal parents I shouldn't say
normal parents but a parent may not
allow so I'll give you an example on
Friday afternoon get home from school um
throw a a a bag a thing of baloney and a
a loaf of bread into a backpack throw it
on my BMX bike grab my tackle box and a
tent and go I don't come back until
Sunday night she has no idea where I am
but she knows that I'm out fishing and I
take my cousin with me of course
um so I see this
as that parent that allows that to
happen is not going to be
prosecuted for for neglect Hey where's
your kid I don't know they're out
fishing they're they're going to be gone
for the weekend and you know what that
was before we had cell phones so she
couldn't track me on GPS couldn't call
me on the phone but she knew if I was in
trouble that I knew how to get help so I
I I see this bill as allowing that type
of uh relationship with a parent uh I
don't see it in the light that you folks
are here I I don't I I understand where
you're coming from but I see it
differently um representative new thank
you Mr chair um I completely agree I I
love the idea of letting my kids T take
risks and and um and you know uh learn
their lumps uh get their lumps and learn
their lessons um I wanted to ask a
question um of Representative Lyn um
since we're all drawing on his expertise
and U my question my question is um you
know when so when it when it says in
here that one of one of the uh kind of
premises here is is there is a reason to
approach to such decision-making that
takes into consideration um benefit
versus risk and what I get stuck on with
that is is reasoned because everyone who
goes into a courtroom has a reason right
everybody's got a reason everybody's got
their reasoning what is it doesn't say
anything about what the the quality of
that reasoning is or kind of what the
standard is that that we would hold that
reasoning to I would think it would need
to be a good argument which in other
words is reasoning am I right
well I you know I guess I think the way
I maybe would respond to that is this I
think that what it's designed to get at
I mean I didn't draft this but what I
think it's maybe what it's designed to
get at is that to say that the person
thought about it um and even if you know
even if the person even if the person
was well even if you might disagree with
their reasoning at least they thought
about it um so that you for example if
the um the the kid left in the in the
hot car um you know if the if the uh if
the parents said well look you know I
was I literally was going in to buy a
package of gum at the 7-Eleven and you
know the the store wasn't crowded and so
you know I didn't I didn't think about
it long but I did think it was only
going to take me like you know a minute
and a half to do this um I would say
that's that's a reason you know you
thought about it as opposed to something
that you just just you know geez I never
even thought about you know I I forgot
my kid was in the car I didn't realize
that my kid was in the back or something
like that you know you might say wait a
minute that's like you know gez you
didn't know that that's you
know so that I I'm not sure that's a
great example but but I so I I want to
emphasize I don't think I have any
particular ex you know any expertise as
as to sort of reading better expertise
than anybody else as to sort of reading
language because it's you know you're
all smart people you can draw your own
say representative Manion thank you Mr
chair um so I'm not as old as
representative PR nor have I ever fallen
down the stairs while cutting a
bagel but I grew up in the 70s and 80s
and I used to race BMX bikes bikes um in
a sanction in a league it wasn't just a
couple of kids in the dirt it was
actually sanctioned we traveled around a
bit so as a result my son started racing
when he he was nine I introduced him to
the sport because the the baseball just
wasn't doing it for him BMX is an
individual sport you win you get the
praise you lose it's on you so he became
state champion in Mass District champion
in New Hampshire but along the way he's
had concussions spraying ankles he broke
his wrist um we were in Baltimore in a
hospital am I now negligent because he
got hurt while entertaining these and he
raced nationally so my my fear is is
that parents who are
having their kids in sanctioned Sports
does are they going to be able to be
charged with this stuff this this would
cover it as far as
emotional damage I guess I mean aside
from severe stuff he would win and feel
good he would lose and feel bad and I
would talk to him about losing and what
he needs to do to get better at it part
of emotional roller coasters and
emotional feelings are part of growing
up it's part of your character it makes
you who you are so there needs to be
some degree of that happening to these
kids while they're children so when
they're adults they're better able to to
cope with this stuff so I I think this
bill's good and I'm going to I'm going
to uh vote to
OTP representative
wheeler thank you Mr
chairman I didn't get a chance to
discuss this in caucus so let me just
say no surprises Ray I did text Linda
about this but Mr chairman I support
this legislation as I think
representative Lynn made the point
better than I could have there's no
statute and law currently after reading
RSA 639 colon 3 that says that the law
respects that children have a right to
grow up in interesting scenarios it's
not always it's not always easy and it
doesn't repeal anything that's already
in 639 colon 3 that statute is very well
written I think and does illustrate what
we are talking about here today it's
child engagement is wrong and it's
illegal under that statute this adds
language to that statute which says that
parents ultimately have the right and
freedom to raise their children if it
goes too far then the sections in that
statute prior to that would come into
play um so Mr chairman I grew up the
same way as many of us have said on you
know it was in the early 2000s but uh I
I grew up in it was just it was just
yesterday it's still baby you want to
withdraw that I grew up part yeah yeah
right there you I am alive because you
know um yeah I don't know if I've
necessarily grown up yet I think you're
right Mr chairman but I do support this
legislation and I will be voting yes on
the OTP thank you um and before I take
other questions I just want to add
something that I think that you um
really hit on that's very important we
should not read this um bill in
isolation this is part of a a broader
statute that already covers a lot of
scenarios that would make a parent
actions illegal in this section clearly
says if it's not in violation of any
other law so therefore a lot of the
concerns we're hearing about are already
covered in law in the rest of the
statute um so up next representative
Murphy thank you thank you Mr chairman
um I have the same concerns that
representative new um has um and
actually if I understand representative
Lynn 's explanation
so so a through D would all have to be
satisfied for um a determination of
endangering the welfare of a child is
that
correct sorry yes in other words if you
wanted to satisfy seven I I think the
way it's worded with the semicolons and
the and I think you'd have to satisfy
all of those okay thank you um which
actually confirms my my concern um my
concern having worked at DCF um with
parents of all sorts and children of All
Sorts is that this part of the statute
would be used to legitimize neglect um I
think it limits the discretion of our
Judiciary I think right now our judges
have the ability to to um take these
things into cons consideration and I
think my sense is that it will
complicate um things the words actual
reasoned um I do know how challenging it
is to um having been a worked at DCF
having been a foster parent an adopted
parent um to prove actual injury or
injury maybe if it's physical it's
easier but harm
um you know I I I I don't know I just I
I don't think I could support this I I
recognize the parents we all let our
kids take risks we we use our own
discretion but um sometimes the
discretion that um brings brings a a
parent to the attention of a court um
maybe different uh than than um what we
would think of within a normal realm of
discretion um you I just I'm I'm afraid
that um children will be hurt by this
and so I I'm not going to support it
thank you thank you um I just want to
make a point um represent Murphy um by
by having to satisfy all of those that's
actually makes it tougher on the parent
in other words if you don't satisfy all
of those it doesn't make you exempt it
says no parent or legal guardian of a
child who makes parenting decisions
shall be guilty of an offense under this
section if so the only way they can be
not guilty of an offense is if they
satisfy all those it's not the other way
around so to in order to Avail
themselves of this they would have to
say okay no one my child wasn't hurt um
the decision wasn't in violation of law
and I have this reasoned approach um and
the decision-making part and it's
keeping with the family Guardians values
so that's I just wanted to make that
point you may respond oh thank you um I
I think I understand that but the my
concern is okay if you know we we don't
prove or or we just say you prove actual
injury or or you miraculously somehow
prove harm um a reasoned approach and
taking into consideration the benefit
versus risk um aligns there with Part D
with the parent of Guardians values what
um once once the injury occurs they're
done they can't use the rest of these is
what my point is so if the child is
injured you can't say yeah they're
injured but it it was reasoned approach
it was you know what I mean they have to
satisfy all
[Music]
those I'm I'm really I'm I am confused
it's not it should if that that were the
case then it wouldn't that say or after
a um well that's what the semicolon is
for I believe and we can go back into
class uh they're
all if it says or that means it
individualizes each of them so if it
says or it's only one AB BC or D that
exactly it doesn't say that which means
it has to be all of them right right so
that's but if you're saying that all we
have to do is prove harm or injury then
the rest don't matter but that's if the
if the colon is
there yeah so in other words okay let's
put yourself in a DCF position you're
back at work you have a kid and you
think you you doing an investigation and
the kid has injury the parent can't use
this statute it's already done because
they have the injury they can't satisfy
all those do you see what I mean or or
if you don't find any injury but it's a
violation of one of the other sections
of law they can't use this or if you
don't if it's not a violation of any of
the laws and there is no injury but they
don't have a reason to approach they
said ah I saw something on a TV show I
thought it would be cool to do my kids
they can't use this um yeah it's it's
got to be they have to get all these in
order to say you can't prosecute me for
being negligent any one of these and
they're done um let me see who was up
representative Pro and just for your
information I see all the hands we're
writing them down I'm letting people who
haven't gone yet go
my concern with the law is we're writing
a specific exception to say you shall
not be guilty we don't do that for a lot
of laws we should do it for a specific
reason I haven't heard the reason yet
I've looked at all the testimony that's
gone forward about they let the kids
play football they got injured they did
all this kind of stuff I just think I
don't understand and I I don't like
these broad exceptions you shall not be
guilty because so and that so I have
that's my problem with this law thank
you and I do take a point of PR Personal
Privilege I my name was used by
representative wheeler and I just want
to let the committee know I am seldom
surprised by anything he
does we know that to be true and that is
noted for the record um representative
balore back to you who else represent
Muse I see you down there I just have a
question if anyone on the committee
wants to speak to
this um gender reassignment surgery is
not illegal and the bill that was passed
by the house recently with your name
attached to it as I understand makes it
a criminal act on the part of the
physician but not the authorizing
parent
so given
that
surgery
isn't injury or harm but a medical
procedure that is illegal much like a
circumcision is a
surgery um the parenting decision is not
in violation of a law there's a reasoned
approach takes into consideration
benefit versus risk as I understand it
typically it's a last resort when the
mental health of the child is at
risk and it's in a decision made in
keeping with a parent or Guardians
Family Values would this explicitly
allow for gender reassignment surgery
for
minors well as long as it's not in
violation of another law I would say
there's a reasonable argument to be made
for that yeah and we currently don't
have a law against it and if that bill
were to pass the Senate and not be
vetoed by the governor it still would
not be illegal for the parent to consent
to that on behalf of the minor that I
don't know I slept at a holiday in last
night but I'm not an attorney um but
it's an interesting interesting line of
questioning I'm glad you brought it up
Muse I I just want to say we should be
extremely careful uh in modifying a
statute like this um this is the
endangering a welfare of a child statute
and and like our domestic violence
statute um these statutes were put
together with the idea of protecting
people who are potential victims and who
are
vulnerable um and it it just strikes me
as strange that in a statute like this
um we would be creating uh an exception
for some for for anybody um uh it just
doesn't seem to be like something that
we should doing and be doing and I think
representative Balden and Murphy have uh
have raised some some excellent points
and um one of the things that I I think
that this statute does can do
potentially is to uh legitim legitimize
uh neglect um and I think that it opens
the door to some unintended in
consequences that um the sponsors and I
think some of the folks in this
committee um
uh may not necessarily uh be in favor of
um I just think it's something that we
need to look at a lot harder before we
pass
it thank you um let me see I would also
remind everyone and I'm not going to say
anybody's name or anything but we do
have a another bill that's before us
that makes exemptions for parents in
jail sentences so when we start saying
well we don't like making exceptions for
anyone for anything um I would remind
you of what what else we have before us
um representative
rhods thank you Mr chairman so I I would
like to address some of the very
specific things that have been brought
up with this
discussion and when this first when this
bill first came in front of us I I I
absolutely hate hated it I I thought
this was not necessary I personally
didn't think there was a very good
argument made of any reason why we
should pass it and then I started
looking into some of the situations have
been brought up today so I know it
shocks some people to to know that I
guess that I have a life outside of here
but I do and one of the things that I
unfortunately have to look at are the
court papers
for child abuse and child neglect
cases and pretty much everything that
has been said I can assure you
absolutely is illegal it will not not be
illegal if this bill were to pass and if
you have a situation
where God forbid a parent throws their
child into a basement and literally
throws down a bag of bread for days at a
time that is illegal and this bill will
not make that be be legal by any means
and you actually are able to prove
emotional harm I know that for a fact
because at my desk I have about six
court documents right now that are all
that their emotional abuse their verbal
abuse um neglect and at the end of the
day even if there's a parent that you
really just don't think is a very good
parent it's amazing if you start talking
about their child they do love their
child the very very few exceptions in
this world or the person does not love
their child so much that they're going
to put them an actual Harm's Way and I
think that that is what this bill was
trying to address was that you know you
you went into I personally will not go
into a convenience store and leave my
purse in the car why would I leave my
kid in the the car if I won't leave my
purse in the car my kids worth more than
my
purse but people choose to do that
should should it be illegal probably not
probably not and I think that that's
what this bill was trying to address so
I I just would like everybody to keep
that in mind when you're when you're
chairman okay with that I think
everyone's had a chance to speak who's
left oh representative scitec you have
not yes I I have no wish to be
unpleasant but I'm going to be I guess
um first I think unlike representative
Newman I think that rep Section 8
improves uh the situation but it I still
don't like the bill it strikes me that
this I do not know of any particular
instance that this is trying to cure it
fattens the books for basically what
seems to me to be I can't articulate
this but it feels like a loyalty oath
somehow uh
I just everything seems to be illegal
that the people have talked about
without reference to this this doesn't
cure or fix anything I I I don't know
it's trying to capture a mood it's
trying to turn back what Society seems
to be we're going to sue you because you
dropped the you tripped over the crack
in the sidewalk there just seems to be a
this is react a reaction to a societal
Trend and
I I I don't like the societal Trend but
I don't think this is going to change it
either so
I I'll vote for the amendment not the
bill one those
rather I wish I had expressed it better
I'm sorry I wasn't around for the to
discuss this
earlier thank you
um oh sure representative uh Harriet
gather thank you Mr chair um I was just
looking at some of the notes from um
that hearing and um I just want it made
known that there was issues with this
bill with the county attorney that was
here that day from
meramac and um you you had at that time
asked him does he see this happening
often and he says quite often is he said
that um endangering of a minor welfare
charges fairly regularly on a
misdemeanor
level and he quoted
6393 section 4 to back up what he was
saying um I also remember that um um
there was another group that was against
the bill as well um new Futures that's
what it was
yes so with that said I I can't support
the bill as it as it reads now
thank you as this is um this is a very
important bill um and I I I I would like
to see if there's a way it seems like we
have a lot of people for it a lot of
people against it if there's any way
that we could um amend the bill so that
we could get we could get broader
support because I don't like Partyline
bills to do with children
um and I'm wondering and I'm going to
ask representative
Lynn you know there's this whole broad
thing about you know re um if it's in
keeping with their values and if it's
they have a reason decision many of our
criminal laws even civil laws have a
have What's called the the reasonable
man or reasonable police officer
reasonable would a reasonable parent
addition to this make it still allow for
protections of a parent but still set
sort of a a societal guideline would
that be helpful you
think well I know I I think it might you
know one one thing that you could
consider as I said before I think to me
the most important
thing is to have because I agree
completely with representative scitech
although I don't agree with the result
he would he would he would reach I I
think that the reason that you need the
something like this in the law is that
we have become I mean there is you know
a a mentality at least in some quarters
out there that we you know we should be
helicopter parents and you shouldn't let
your child take any risk and if you if
and particularly if a child gets hurt um
then we're you know we really want to
use 2020 hindsight to say oh you
shouldn't have taken that risk or um
whatever and I and so I think it
something there ought to be something in
the law that addresses that and what I'm
wondering is suppose you took out SE par
paragraph seven altogether and just left
in paragraph 8 I mean that you know that
does sort of say look it's okay for
parents to take reasonable risk and you
know if I this if I can just if I I I
this is something I remember for you
know I'm 74 years old so it's a long
time ago no but I'll give you just let
give when I was like in seventh grade I
think it was seventh grade back in West
Haven Connecticut there was this guy
that was this other co- other student
that was that was you know constantly
picking on me just constantly picking on
me and he had he had so he had he had
probably more friends than I did and I
was really kind of a wimp and so you
know I kept I I was raised by my mother
and my great-grandmother and I kind of
was you know I was really really afraid
frankly and I um sort of you know said
to my mother well you know what I'm
really having this having this trouble
and she was thinking you know I I should
I should maybe I should go to the school
author and I said no no you can't do
that it'll just make it just worse for
me if you do that kind of thing and my
great grandmother who we lived with
which who was God she had to be in her
70s by then she said you know I think
you just need to take this guy on I
think you just you know maybe you'll get
a punch in the nose um but it but but in
the end that may be the best thing and
so that's what I did and we had a we had
we literally had a physical fight and
you know we both we both inflicted a
little Dan not nobody got hurt and any
you know significantly but we both we
both got bloodied a little bit
and after that you that was the end you
know I mean we didn't become friends but
that was the end of the that was sort of
the end of the him picking on me and so
I guess the question you know in that
situation should my great-grandmother be
charged with neglect you know if some if
a police officer came along and said and
found that I had you know a bloody nose
or whatever um and you talked to me and
I said oh well you know my
great-grandmother said look this is the
this is you know it's this is I think
this has be the right thing to do do you
might get a punch in the nose but it'll
maybe this will end it if if this guy at
least knows it you're not going to you
know you're willing to stand up to him
and it turned out she was right but
would a police officer now or a
prosecutor say you know boy she you know
the great grandmother encouraged him to
have a fight let's lock her up I I hope
not but that's I think that's the thing
that there ought to be something in the
law that says if the police you know if
if that kind of situation comes up um
the the police are going to think twice
about charging my great-grandmother with
with uh with a
crime thank you and I just wanted to
that's that's a very good point and I
like that idea maybe just strike that um
that whole thing and just leave the
leave the amended piece that that just
leaves it for the court to decide but
says this is our preference and I wanted
to as an example um representative
Balden had brought up the U the
transgender issue and I just saw in the
news um in California um the state had
taken children away from their parents
because they refused to use
pronouns again I mean is that
endangerment is that because you I I
don't know um but I think we need some
guidelines and I agree representative
Murray you have your Qui hand raised
thank you Mr chair
um I I wanted to say that I I like
representative Lynn's proposal and I
actually was going to suggest the same
thing I I think my biggest concern with
the bill is the kind of loopholes that
um the guidelines here can create and um
my concern is less about um you know I'm
against helicopter parenting and I do
think kids should be allowed to take
some risk um and I was allowed to do the
same as a child it's almost the opposite
um in terms of like what loopholes this
can create by saying like if a parent or
a family you know has certain values or
beliefs like they can do all these
things like we can't
possibly uh Outlaw every potential
negative thing that can happen to a
child and so I think it's really
important to just have um the ability
for judges to uh look at the statute and
have the discretion to determine whether
harm is happening to the child and I
think just this paragraph 8 in here
makes it clear that um parents have the
ability to allow their children to take
reasonable risks to further their
development as independent human beings
I completely agree with that line and I
do think it's important for
kids um to be independent take those
risks I also just wanted to make an
aside um that feel like there's been a
trend in the committee lately to bring
up transgender issues for I know I'm not
blaming but I'm just saying as the only
transperson in this committee it's just
not a great feeling to have people try
and make points of um by using my
community as you know a just something
to go back and forth about it just
doesn't make me feel good um and I just
wanted to ask that people will be
respectful of
that we will try and take that into
account um representative
Murphy thank you and I wonder if if
maybe uh representative link could help
me um on that on the amendment um that's
that proposed language is it my question
is is it currently a violation of U this
section for parents to allow children to
take re uh reasonable risks is
that I mean if we I would I guess I
would say no I would think that
that I hope that that's that that's what
the law is now but I I guess what I was
sort of saying is it probably is a good
idea to put that in statute to sort of
have you know to be able to have
somebody be able to say look it's right
in the law that you can do this um even
though it even though you know it might
be you might read that by implication
into the current Law Without this I
think there's a value to having it in
other words legislative intent right
right just follow up and just and just
on the in terms of the word um what what
is your thought about the term
reasonable I now um the chair raised a
point earlier um should there be a
reasonable I would I would say no I
think that you know that um you know
it's for examp you know in the in the uh
uh in the self-defense statutes and
stuff like that you know you it's pretty
General language you can use you can use
deadly force or you can use non deadly
force if you have a reasonable belief so
it you know there's there reasonable is
reasonable the word reasonable or
reasonableness is used quite a bit in in
this area thank you so it's in some
cases it's specific in other words I's
say would a similarly situated a
reasonable police officer do this but in
a broad sense of society we just assume
a reasonable human human being is that
is that what
you okay so gotcha representative scitec
and I see you uh first I want to thank
representative Lynn because your opening
remarks articulated what I was trying to
say about the helicopter parents and
we're we may be micromanaging parenting
to some extent I sort of uh my I feel my
Sullen this has somewhat been lifted
here because of that I I think the idea
of number eight Roman 8 by itself while
it is it is somebody stole my line I was
going to say legislative intent that
this just sets a tone for how things are
looked at judicially and just you just
have a sense that the legislature
understands that your reasonable parents
do reasonable things and I I would like
to just see rep uh section8 as the as
thank you Mr chair so what I was
thinking um to kind of piggyback off of
U what representative Murray was saying
is that um I I I think that it would be
it would actually accomplish what we
wanted to accomplish the intent of what
we want to accomplish to have something
that is um like eight um and otherwise
what seven does is it gets into um more
specific and it creates more problematic
more more problems where um what she
what um representative Mario was saying
earlier um is the idea that we all have
kind of a specific situation in our head
right and in whether it's helicopter
parenting or whether it's the opposite
end of that Spectrum um getting to you
know what is reasonable and what what
you know where we as a society say these
are the parameters of what we think what
is acceptable and what is not in the
best interest of the child what we're
really asking here is to um to make a a
statement of intent and say you know uh
we want this to be taken into
consideration which would also bring it
back into line with the other
legislation that we uh referenced
without names um that you know is really
just saying hey this would be a good
thing to consider when we're um
sentencing or or deciding somebody's
punishment
okay yeah I just want to ask a question
uh and it has to do with if you're
trying to make it more bipartisan bill
um I was surprised by section two of the
law that says in the in the prosecution
of any person under this section the
tattooing or branding of any person or a
child under the age of 20 of 18
constitutes endangering the welfare of
such child would this would this now
make tattooing people legal if
you're no because remember if we were
going to amend it and just leave Section
8 which says it's a violation it's not a
violation of this section for parents to
allow children take reasonable risks and
further development of their human
beings the the previous part has already
clearly delineated needed in in statute
would would Trump that in my opinion
would would you agree thank you agree
yeah thank you um okay with with that um
because we have a lot of work to do
today we're going to um we're going to
uh recess this until later on in the day
then with that I open the executive
session on House Bill 1038 and I
recognize representative
amendment is that right I read
you
yes so this this bill um oh I make a
motion
29h seconded by representative Murray
can you just repeat that amendment
number please yes it's 08
29h give everyone a second to get the
amendment
on would you like to speak to your
motion representative Manion I would yes
thank you so we heard this bill last
year um we had a subcommittee on it and
uh all the parties uh and all the all
the parties involved came up with this
amendment to the bill uh was
reintroduced this year however they it
the represent representative we'll be
taking a vote pretty quick the
voting okay it was introduced as the
original bill so what this amendment is
is this is the amendment that we passed
last year in committee it also passed to
the house um so for those reasons I
would I would suggest we uh adopt this
amendment and ought to pass thank you
represent Murray would you like to speak
um I agree with my
colleague discussion um we passed this
last year um I don't know I don't recall
what he said happened to it something
about the the other body but um I don't
I don't see any changes um is there any
discussion on it representative Muse one
thing one of the things that I wanted to
say is what the amendment basically does
is it puts the bill back into exactly
the same thing that we sent over to the
Senate that was interim studied last
year
um it in a way it it kind of feels like
um expecting different results by doing
the same thing all over again um but um
I did support the bill then I was on the
subcommittee I'll support it again this
time uh but I I do wish the sponsor
might have done uh a little bit more to
get the bill in better shape to actually
survive the next step of the process
it's my understanding the Senate um that
the um sponsor spoke to um people over
there and they encouraged him to refile
it so it might be just one of those um
Lucy in the football things again I do
not know we'll see representative Manion
thank you Mr chair I also want to note
that this has the longest sentence if
you remember last year uh in any bill
that we filed and uh it would be nice to
get it into law yes I I always strive
for the Guinness book in my legislation
representative Murray thank you Mr chair
I was just going to um add from my
recollection the Senate interim studied
it so they could see if similar laws had
been passed in other states or if there
was any federal law that was in conflict
and from what the sponsor said um there
was no conflict found um so that uh yeah
I do believe it will be passed by the
Senate this time God bless you in your
memory um with that I would ask you to
call the role on the amendment the
motion is ought to pass on the amendment
the amendment number is 0829 H as in
Hotel by
Vice chair roads yes representative
Pratt yes representative scitec
representative PR yes representative
janen yes representative Manion yes
representative Reed yes representative
Lynn repres sorry representative tenar
yes representative Harry gother yes
representative Muse yes representative
bden yes representative Bradley yes
representative Murphy yes representative
Newman yes the clerk votes yes
representative Newell yes representative
celik yes representative wheeler y
chairman Roy chot chess
20 20 the amendment is adopted um I
recognize representative Manion to make
a motion thank you Mr chair I make a
motion ought to pass as
amended second seconded by
representative appr would you like to
speak to your motion thank you Mr chair
I think we covered it uh with my
first U speech
representative
Pro ditto agreed um anyone else want to
say
anything seeing none I would ask the
clerk to call the role on the um Au to
passes
amended Vice chair roads yes
representative Pratt yes representative
scitec representative PR yes
representative janen yes representative
Manion representative Reed yes
representative
Stone sorry representative Lynn yes
representative tzar yes representative
Harry gther yes representative Muse yes
representative Bolton yes representative
Bradley yes representative Murphy yes
representative Newman yes the clerk
votes yes representative Newell yes
representative cig yes representative
wheeler yay chairman Roy chair votes yes
20 Z 20 passes unanimously any objection
to consent see none it goes on consent
calendar uh hereby close the executive
session okay and um well I'm about to
open the second one uh in about two
minutes um if anyone in here is um using
their electronic devices to tweet or
anything about that we're doing right
now please refrain I've been pretty um
pretty LAX on on the electronic device
stuff and I want to stay that way so we
had an agreement to not do that when we
started this so let's please continue
that we can talk about it after um with
that the next bill up hold on I just got
to wait for repes representative rhs to
come back with a pen and a
paper with that I open the executive
session on House Bill 1039
FN and I
recognize
motion um I want to be begin with a
Amendment um
852 as in house and um if that's not
palatable I'm happy to
withdraw and uh consider another motion
let's talk about it um seconded seconded
she
be uh representative s uh motion
of adopting the amend amendment was by
off representative bden would you like
to speak to your Amendment
representative bden can you just give me
the amendment
H
[Music]
um so we had a very long bill um the
amendment makes it a very short Bill the
language was suggested to um
representative Harry gathright by
Representative Bob Linn who happens to
be here today he said that his suggested
language is not um necessarily an
endorsement of the bill just that he
said that um for the for the purpose of
achieving the intended goal of the bill
that this would this language would um
fit there was a testimony from the
county attorney's
office um
that judges already have the ability to
do what what the bill was trying to
accomplish um
and representative Lynn said in
suggesting this language that it would
make it absolutely clear that that um
wiggle room is available to judges that
discretion is available to judges so
that makes sense to me and it being my
bill I'm fine with this amendment um but
if there's a lot of opposition I'm open
to another motion so that we can take
some time over the summer to work on
this and but at the same time I think
that also the support quarters of the
original legislation are satisfied at
this point with this wording um and I
don't expect any push back from them and
as far as the concerns from the
Coalition um I anticipate that the
brevity of this um amended version um
which would be the entirety of the bill
would satisfy their concerns as it
relates to the long list of P um
offenses that were in the original
legislation and are now absent in the
amendment
would you like to speak to your
second sorry thank you
um um I I fundamentally agree that it's
important to just
codify the importance of Judges using
discretion and considering all factors
and ensuring that they
do thank you and we're open for
discussion representative
SCI I can't help but notice the echo to
uh the direction of that we went with
1012 can I respond sure um I mean unlike
1012 um this just says the court may
consider not must consider 1012 gives
more I think explicit Direction um in
the uh process of determining whether or
not to charge someone so the court may
consider
all facts and circumstances which you
know if if we are in agreement that this
just further
clarifies an option that the courts
already have then if it is like 1012 in
either okay I think let's talk about the
substance of the bill now um anyone
else oh representative
Murphy thank you um I was part part of
the sub subcommittee that um heard this
bill and um as I had had stated during
those discussions I was not in support
of it as written um I do support the
amendment um my concern had been prior
uh that it didn't address vulnerable
persons as the victim um and I and the
number of carve outs I think it just
sort of complicated things even though
um we've been told that the court
already has this ability to to have
discretion think this is a a good uh and
more broad um reminder and um I think
that's the piece that I know um those
that testified had suggested that even
though the court had that discrep
discretion they didn't feel it was
always used so um I support um this 1039
as
amended thank you um I too opposed the
um the previous version um for for the
various reasons that have been discussed
and I'm I'm trying to find a reason why
I should hate this one but it's
difficult so um it does seem to do what
we said in the previous Bill and so far
as it sets a legislative intent that we
want you to look at this and and take it
into account um even though they may
already do so it says just basically
while you're sentencing this person keep
in mind to the extent you you think it's
relevant that they do have other people
to care
about I think um representative scitec
had something more to say or at least I
should say representative scitec I'm not
very good at reading lips and that's why
baseball okay and trouble
[Music]
understanding
Murray thank you Mr chair um yeah I
guess I I know we've talked about this
but I just want to reiterate the
amendment just simplifies the bill
removes all the controversial material
so that we are ensuring that judges are
aware that they do have the discretion
to take um this information into
consideration when they're creating a
sentence um and I think whether we move
forward with the amendment and attempt
to pass the bill or interim study we
should um continue studying this issue
over over the summer with all the um
Advocates who have um a vested interest
in this um and I think the point
representative scitec was trying to make
was just that in the way that we
simplified 1012 so we could all agreeing
it I think that's what we're trying to
do
here okay oh thank
you further
discussion M Mr chair I have a question
or I'm very confused because the the the
bill that I have in in all of my notes
so now is the is the amendment wiping
out the bill and then just telling a
judge that they may do something that
they already are aware that they may
do um I believe it it replaces the
entire Bill and it calls to the
attention of the Court similarly to we
just discussed in the previous bill that
the legislature wants them to um
consider this even though they may
already um it it gives it a highlight
but I don't I don't see any mandate that
they have to um or
that or that it it it says they should
give preference to them over versus
other um convicted person so I don't I
don't
see I don't see it being any different
really than the previous one um but if
if if someone else thinks that I'd be
happy to hear
answer that repr wheeler hold
on not this isn't in direct response to
your question and actually I might be
about to say the same thing as I might
I'm going to defer to Linda actually
representative goth representative goth
right yes um if you remember we had
testimony
that this wasn't being used okay we know
that the judge has discretion and this
was brought about because it was not
being used so what we thought what be a
good thing after talking to
representative Flynn that we would look
at um just putting something in there as
a remembrance that this is this should
happen normally but it's not being
happening and that's how the bill came
before
us okay um as this is a a significant
change from what we had prepared to
discuss and deal with today I'm going to
I'm going to Res recess this one to the
same time it's 10:12 this afternoon and
we will take these two bills up again at
that point um
and deal with it then with that I open
the executive session on House
Bill
1021 and I recognize representative
Manion to make a motion thank you Mr
chair I make a motion to itl do I have a
second seconded by um representative
sake would you like to speak to your
motion representative Manion I would
thank you so this bill um is covering a
couple different areas in our body word
camera
law one part of it is requiring the
defendant to receive a physical copy of
the body One camera for defense uh in
May of this year the marac
Superior Court ruled that that's what's
to be done so initially whether the way
the bill was written and the way body
one cams were given out was just a link
to it that they could watch the they
couldn't have a hard copy of it that
case law changed that so that's what
we're doing now another part of this
bill is that the defendant wants the
ability to share these and display them
as he sees fit that could be on YouTube
that could be anywhere else and I'm I'm
strongly against
that another part of it was exculpatory
evidence not to be destroyed uh it's not
destroyed I can tell you right now
anything that's an arrest is held for
minimum of three years uh in most
departments and I know the ones I've
worked for it's 10 years for felonies so
it's automatically destroyed providing
that the case is completely disposed of
um it requires a court order we get
thousands and thousands of videos a year
so to get a court order for every single
one every time one the time has expired
on it would be a a Monumental task so
and I don't think there's there's the
time to do that so most of what this
bill is trying to accomplish is already
being
done thank you representative s would
you like to speak to a second ditto
any further discussion representative
Newman I just want to commend represent
Manion for for explaining our
subcommittee in less than a
minute that is admirable indeed further
discussion seeing none I would ask the
cour to call the role motional floor is
ought to no excuse me is inexpedient to
legislate Vice chair roads yes
representative Pratt yes representative
scitec yes representative PU yes
representative janen yes representative
Manion yes representative Reed yes
representative Lynn yes representative
tzar yes representative Harry cite yes
representative Muse yes representative
Balton yes representative Bradley yes
representative Murphy yes representative
Newman yes the clerk votes yes
representative Newell yes representative
celik yes representative wheeler yay
chairman Roy chair votes yes 20 20 the
motion of inexpedient to legislate
passes unanimously any objection to
consent seeing none go on consent hereby
close the executive session on House
Bill 1021 I open the executive session
on House Bill
1061 and I recognize representative tzar
for a motion thank you Mr chairman I
make a motion of itl I'll second second
representative here
gaite would you like to speak to your
motion representative tenzer uh yes I
would thank you Mr chairman uh this bill
makes driving an uninspected motor
vehicle a secondary offense in the state
of New Hampshire uh currently all of the
violations of the rules of the road
inspection or registration are primary
offenses which means a police officer
Deputy or Trooper can stop uh stop the
vehicle I have issues with this because
it's going to be making a two-tiered
system which can gradually make law
enforcement not able to do their jobs uh
the whole goal of law enforcement is to
prevent the violation of the law and
also to stop the violation of the law um
uh for the record I'm a retired Trooper
of the tens of thousands of vehicles I
stopped probably thousand or so were uh
inspection violations I'll let you know
that I did not write much of any tickets
on those the whole goal was to let the
person know hey by the way you're
uninspected get get it fixed whatever
you need to do I think that the sponsor
also alluded to that this would be a
pretext for a search uh that's not going
to happen I just think this is a really
bad Bill and it just opens up for the
problems with law enforcement helping to
correct behaviors
thank you um representative got here at
gather like speak to you a second well
set thank you I I would also like to add
that
um this claim of a pretextual for search
um you can stop a vehicle for just about
anything if you don't have problem cost
to search you're not searching um so
just because you stopped it for a
sticker versus a tail light versus
anything it doesn't help you get into
search of vehicle having said that on
often what you see on the outside of a
body is indicative of what's going on
inside your body and when you see a a a
sticker that's expired or
whatever sometimes it's indicative that
the registration is also expired that
their license is un uh has been
suspended um and so on and so forth so
to to say to our law enforcement enforce
these laws this is what we want but kind
of don't enforce
it sends a horrible message to law
enforcement so with that oh
representative Manion thank you Mr chair
and maybe representative ly could uh if
I'm wrong correct me on this the
sterndale decision made your car almost
as difficult as your home to search
without a warrant so um with that being
said in my career and I've been alarm
for 30 years if I stop someone for a
sticker I'm probably not giving them a
ticket uh unless you're driving a brand
new mercedesbenz and it's been two years
is and you just decided you weren't
getting one but maybe I'm just a big
softy so I didn't give out a lot of
tickets for
that thank you if I may
inquire in your experience though um is
it also not um out of or unusual to find
that the person may also not be
registered and may also not have a
active license Etc yeah that's been my
experience so you find other things uh
with it thank you um did you want to say
representative Murray
thank you Mr chair well first I was
wondering if I could ask my colleague um
I was just curious what you meant by a
two-tiered system um is that in
reference to like some violations being
prosec or you know pulled over and some
not so yes this uh thank you for the
question this would make the uninspected
motor vehicle a secondary offense so
that I would have to see another offense
on top of that before I can even pull
you over and I just see that this could
now be uninspected then next thing you
know it's registration and everything
else I just think the police should have
the discretion to stop to do their job
the way they should and to not start
micromanaging all of the the violations
of of the
statutes thank you can I
continue thank you um thank you for your
explanation um I guess the one thing I
wanted to add is that um I I respect
obviously all of your experience and
what you've seen out in the field but um
in my experience as a young person most
of the time when I didn't have my car
inspectors cuz I didn't have the money
to inspect it and you know get
a a ticket um would have only made that
situation worse you know when I was in
my early 20s I would dread my birthday
every year because I had to pay uh
inspection and registration fees um and
it just kind of like alarms me a little
bit if people are going in with the
assumption that like because their car
is unexpected then they must more than
likely be guilty of other
offenses um and I think because of that
I will be uh voting against the itl
motion although again I do respect and
understand the perspectives you're
bringing to the
table thank you representative and I do
respect your your opinion and view as a
young person I would however um say that
there are great many of our criminal
statutes that that could possibly be
caused by the fact that you know someone
just doesn't have the money and um we
can't
unfortunately I guess I'd I'd rather say
we need to fix our economy more than we
do our laws um so then you'd have more
money to pay for your your
Pro and I don't think that's what they
said is that they stopped them for uh an
inspection sticker and were trying to
look for more things wrong they dis
appeared right but and and to me
inspections are there for safety right
that you have brakes so you can stop and
all those things um so having your car
not
inspected um can lead to more accidents
right because I I see them from time to
time where things don't work and or your
car just stops in the middle of the road
and somebody slams into you so we need
to keep our vehicles
inspected thank you represent PR that's
a that's a really um gets us really back
to the point and the point is that we
have these for these stickers for safety
and it's about the saf of the motoring
Community um we kind of got sidetracked
on the I think it's representative
lynfall because he got us into all
criminal justi stuff um representative
rhods thank you Mr chairman so I I'm
trying to remember and I take a my notes
on my little on my little notepad here I
guess or my my bill and I do remember
when the sponsor was here and we were
trying to ask him questions there was a
lot of questions that he wasn't able to
answer and along that path
it kind of came out that he didn't want
cars to be inspected at all and he even
said that he said well we've been trying
for years to make inspection go away and
it can't so we thought this would at
least be something to get started that
was his words um there was a question
about you know if your light comes on
and you you know you you can't afford to
find out what it is you can't afford the
the mechanic pretty much every one of
the the large box Autoport stores now
will tell you what is wrong with your
car for free I know for an example
because right now I have a light that I
can't get off and my car is stalling at
red lights it's great I was behind
Representative no this morning and
almost needed right here um that doesn't
cost anything and additionally it is not
an injustice to anybody to have to get
your car inspected you know all year
that it's coming up and you know along
with that representative PR said it best
like what is the point what is the
purpose of an inspection it's not to
make anybody feel like it's a gotcha or
to have to do something everybody has to
do it so you know I I think that we need
to take that part into
consideration thank you um I think we've
talked about stickers enough um I'd ask
the clerk to call the
role motion of floor is in expedient to
legisl Vice chair root yes
representative Pratt yes representative
scitec representative crew yes
representative janen yes representative
Manion yes representative Reed yes
representative Lynn yes representative
tenar yes representative har gther yes
representative Muse yes representative
Balden yes representative Bradley no
representative Murphy yes representative
Newman yes the clerk votes no
representative Newell yes representative
C
no representative wheeler yay uh uh
chairman Roy chairman yes 173 173 I
don't think I can go on consent can it
um with I think it can does anyone
object the
consent all right we're going to try and
put it on consent with that um I close
the executive session what was the
173 I open the executive session on
1097 and recognize
I think you wrote 1197
representative Muse were you going to
make this
motion yeah let him do for which Bill uh
1097 is it 1197 or 119 no it's I was
going to make a motion to
1097 conversations
1097 maybe you me 1197 or yeah 1197 1097
I got ahead of myself to with the 97s
with representative uh with um um bill
number 1097 I recognize myself for a
motion um of inexpedient to legislate
can I get a second seconded by
representative roads um I'll speak to my
motion this is uh again going back to
the question of do we want um our
conversations
recorded um without both people knowing
there's a recording
um it it there's been it's kind of like
the ocean tides it comes in comes out
however speaking for myself I do not
feel comfortable with the idea that I
can at any point be having a
conversation to with someone personally
that I think is private and personal and
all the while it being recorded and then
later on in the afternoon it's on the
internet and it's just it's it's it's a
creepy feeling and I we've years we have
said that we want our privacy we even
put it in the
Constitution um I just think that this
is a violation of privacy and it also
starts getting into questions about
what's um domestic issues um people
setting people up picking fights with
someone and Inter turning on a recorder
after the other person's at up and only
recording that portion of it it's it
just I don't think any good comes from
it um representative Ro you want to
speak to your a second no thank you
anyone else discussion representative
site yeah I'll be opposed to that
because I've all we're we're trying to
stop technology uh I can have something
a pen in my pocket that records it's my
right to privacy you can't search me to
tell me I can't use my pen uh what
should be done with this is the C the uh
it should be said that you cannot use
that recording for any legal purpose
that would be the step I would be
willing to take that you could take it
you can like I listened to my one time I
listened to an accountant doing a lot of
technical things and I wanted to mul
that over so I I didn't want to be
taking notes I'm trying to concentrate
on what he's saying so I let the machine
take the notes he didn't like
it and that's the point you should ask
hey do you mind if I record this so that
later on I can do it and if he says I do
not want you to record me thank you very
much you may not do so any other further
discussion seeing none the motion of the
floor as inexpedient to legislate I'll
ask clerk to call the role Vice chair
roads yes representative Pratt yes
Representative scitec no representative
PR yes representative janen yes
representative Manion yes representative
Reed yes representative Lynn yes
representative tenar yes representative
Harry goth yes representative Muse yes
representative Balon yes representative
Bradley yes representative Murphy yes
representative Newman yes the clerk
votes yes representative Newell yes
representative celik yes representative
wheeler yay chairman Roy chair votes yes
19 wton representative sitec do you
object to consent not at all the bill go
on consent 111 motion carries close the
executive session excuse me 19 to1 yeah
something like that um with that I open
the executive session on House Bill 1197
motion
thank you Mr
chair um I would like to
move uh let me
number
uh amendment number
97h and move on to pass with
Amendment
represent M would you like to speak to
your
motion yes thank you um this is a bill
that was introduced by representative
muns and uh what it would essentially do
is authorize additional state agencies
to take uh f prints of people who are
undergo undergoing non-criminal
background checks uh so one of the
things that came up uh uh during Co is
the system that actually does that
that's operated by the department of
safety was very very much overtaxed so
part of what this bill is about is if we
ever run into a situation like that
again um it's being able to take the
burden off of the Department of Safety
so we don't put a burden on to uh
employers and state departments and
other folks who basically need to uh
pass these background checks uh you know
to make sure that people they're hiring
uh uh don't have criminal records and
things of that nature so um uh what the
amendment uh essentially does is a is is
a couple of things um uh perhaps the the
biggest thing that the amendment does is
it changes uh the effective date which
was one of the biggest objections uh
that the Department of Health and Human
Services had um they were concerned uh
about potentially about some of the cost
C uh and so by moving the effective date
out outwards one of the things that that
does is it puts us outside the current
budget cycle uh it also allows the task
force that would be created um to look
at the implementation of the bill it
actually gives them time to figure out
things like how many machines are needed
uh where are the best places to deploy
them how exactly are they going to be
deployed and to get a better idea what
the potential cost of doing something
like that would be uh so uh so
essentially the bill uh was supported by
the department of safety they think that
this is going to take uh part of the
burden off of them uh and uh I uh I uh
urge you to pass
it thank you um representative s would
you like to speak to your second thank
you uh I
agree as do I further
discussion seeing none I'd ask clerk to
call the role motion is to adopt the
amendment Vice chair roads
yes representative
Pratt yes representative scitec yes
representative pu yes representative
Janan yes representative Manion yes
representative Reed yes representative
Lynn yes representative tenar yes
representative harri aite yes
representative Muse yes representative
Balon yes representative Bradley yes
representative Murphy yes representative
Newman yes the clerk votes yes
representative new
yes representative selik yes
representative wheeler yay chairman Roy
chair votes yes 20 zero 20 to zero the
amendment is adopted represent M would
you like to make a motion yes I I move
uh HB 1197 not to pass with Amendment
second by representative here at gaite
would you like to speak to your motion
representative M I think I I spoke to it
effectively in the uh in the amendment
representative har
gather um for the discussion seeing none
the motion is out to pass with amendment
I would ask clerk to call the role Vice
chair roads yes representative Pratt yes
representative scitec yes representative
pu yes representative
janen yes representative Manion yes
representative Reed yes representative
uh Lynn yes representative tenar yes
representative har cther yes
representative Muse yes representative
Balon yes yes representative Bradley yes
representative Murphy yes representative
Newman yes the clerk votes yes
representative Newell yes representative
sake yes representative wheeler yes
chairman Roy chair votes yes 20 Z 20 Z
any objection to consent motion carries
beond the consent calendar I close the
executive session we are going to take a
back
I'm uh going to
reopen
hello hello
hello I'm going to reopen the executive
session
on what is that
bill on House Bill
1039 and representative Balden wanted to
um make a I'd like to withdraw my I to
pass this minuted motion and make a
motion of uh interim study who seconded
that would you withdraw your
motion okay um is there a second on the
motion of interim study seconded by
representative wheeler would you like
Balden um the stakeholders are in
agreement with interim
study good enough for me further
discussion seeing none the motion to the
floor is interim study on House Bill
1039 and I would ask the clerk to call
the
role Vice chair roads yes representative
Pratt yes representative scitec yes
representative pu yes please
representative janen yes representative
Manion yes representative Reed yes
representative Lynn yes representative
tenar yes representative Harry gther
representative Muse yes representative
Balon yes representative Bradley yes
representative Murphy yes representative
Newman yes the clerk votes yes
representative Newell yes representative
cik yep representative
wheeler Roy Gerald's yes 20 20 motion
carries inexpedient excuse me um interim
study and the bill number okay um
actually um any objection to
consent none it'll go on consent
executive session is closed I'm going to
reopen the executive session
on where is it um decisions no no the
the trespass
bill that's what I'm looking
for
yes
1204 does anybody have the amendment for
House Bill 1204 the one that we just
on okay um I open the executive session
again on House Bill 124 and I'm going to
offer amendment
number 0839
H can I get a second second second repr
roads um this was a technical change as
requested
um I believe who requested that he
changed this think you was it you yeah
maybe
um it was making it U more the bill more
um fit better with the current statutes
it's a statutory placement um Amendment
the bill still is pretty much the same
this bill um would make it so that um
law enforcement if they were going to
enter on your property that has no
trespassing signs they have to honor the
no trespassing signs and they have to
get a warrant if they need to it still
exempts fishing game they can go in the
property it exempts exent circumstances
if they there's an emergency where
evidence could be destroyed or removed
um trying to think of all the possible
exit and circumstances fishing game
issues are are um for example if you
wound an animal and it runs onto the
property you can still get it um
basically it's just it's an answer to
the age-old um as we heard in testimony
Open Fields Doctrine where the US
Supreme Court has said that if it's not
part of the curtilage which is
immediately surrounding your house that
use every day law enforcement can go
wherever they like on your property and
do whatever they want we heard examples
of um cameras being placed the sponsor
sent me several I challenged him and he
met the the challenge he sent me three
different cases that have in the
Hampshire Juris Prudence where they have
cited the the um Open Fields Doctrine um
and allowed police to do this I have
spoken with representative Lynn he said
he's unaware of it so that means the
cases are older
but the fact that they're old doesn't
matter that means they haven't been
overturned so theoretically the open
field Doctrine still applies in New
Hampshire this would as I said require
law enforcement to do the same thing
they would have to do with your house
with your property unless they were the
exemptions that are already in the uh in
the bill such as exent circumstances and
such they have to get a search warrant
would you like to speak to Second
represent
BRS no thank
you discussion represent Newman I would
just like some
help I would just like some help with
the wording of the amendment to find out
where I start to compare the various
things that have been changed and no
longer changed and it's got several laws
in here sure let's um let's get the
please represent Murray thank you Mr
chair from what I can remember
um uh I believe that this is removing
the references to the body camera
statute yes that's it thank you again
for your memory the body camera statute
is already covered in statute um if you
recall the original Bill said that they
had to have their body cameras on
whenever they went on the property and
um that conflicted with the law we
already recently passed regarding body
cameras so that's what the amendment
does it removes references the body
cameras thank you thank
you
yep
exactly reing yeah represent wheeler
thank you Mr chairman I'm gonna be
voting oh to to pass on this bill I
think you know if it's your property uh
and you have it posted that the state
should not be able to wander on that
property and uh the Open Fields dotion
seems silly to me if if it it's not
posted then the police have the ability
to go onto the property that seems
appropriate and consistent with New
Hampshire law and I think that if it is
posted the police because you have
posted it should have to listen to that
posting and contact you and get
permission to go on your property or get
a search warn if needed um so I'll be
voting for the aop pass on this you um I
I would also I'd like to kind of address
um the hunting issue
um because we discussed in a previous
Bill about hunting and this kind of
references again your personal property
our trespass laws in New Hampshire are
are pretty detailed um and that's for
good
reason you can post your property no
trespassing that means nothing you can
post your property no hunting that means
you can still go hiking walking the
police would still be able to walk
through there but if Hunters cannot go
on there so you could post your property
no ATVs you can post it any way you want
and be very specific in how you do so
and that is what would trigger the
trespass part but if you put no
trespassing that means nobody nothing
zero including the police unless they
have a warrant so I think that that kind
of covers that um representative sake
thank you um I just had a question one
of the people who testified was um John
J did you say jingle Harbor Schmid maybe
I don't know I can't read my own
handwriting here um but from the state
Department of Labor who raised concerns
about um the broadness of all government
agents which I don't believe is covered
through your Amendment but he um
referenced that it would make it
difficult in terms of
enforcing um uh inspections uh related
to different things like labor laws or
uh conditions in workplaces and I don't
see that addressed at all um if you
recall I questioned him about that and
he admitted that really no because this
really applies to single family homes
and they don't do labor laws in single
family homes this is about that's about
businesses um in a business if they want
to enforce labor laws in a business
they're going to go into the building
which is curtilage anyway which isn't
impacted by this this is about the Open
Fields Doctrine so unless the labor
department is going out in the woods
behind my house doing something to
somebody's doing labor out there which
uh I don't even I can't even imagine the
scenario I think that they were just
being overly cautious um I can't if
anyone can think of a scenario where the
labor department would need to be in the
woods behind your house if you have an
elevator in the woods May yeah you could
have a Woods elevator um but beyond that
his their duties generally 99% of the
time are going to be with industrial
properties and things of that nature so
um once you had admitted that really
they were just kind of doing a belt in
suspenders I didn't see the need to
address that representative um um
chairman I I'm kind of in a at a loss
here I wasn't here for the public
hearing but I will say this uh I am
actually a member of a planning board
and planning board has very large um
latitude and and
inspection um this would appear that it
would apply to members of the planning
board Conservation Commission zoning
board etc etc um whereas the statute
dealing with those those boards give
them the right to inspect at any time
without a warrant this is now telling
them they have to go get an
administrative inspection warrant which
I think is contrary to what I believe we
want already uh well first of all um
they can get landowner permission to go
look at whatever on their property but I
don't see where any government agency I
don't care if it's the planning board
whoever should be on the my property
without my permission um and if there's
a statute that says that they're allowed
to traes around my property um finally I
I find that offensive I think that it's
my property and if I post it no
trespassing I mean no trespassing not no
trespassing except for people who want
to come look at it for planning purposes
um you know we may disagree on that but
that's that's my again we we heard from
the
trooper it's your home's Your Castle
it's my castle contrary to what the TR
said though I did find cases where the
New Hampshire police have done just that
so he he also when I asked him why if
they're already doing it why would it
hurt to pass the statute and we really
didn't get a good answer for that um so
and with regard to that I didn't see
anyone from the municipal Association
here to testify against it and generally
if there's an issue with it they would
be out against it and we didn't have any
contrary
testimony representative Newman i' just
like to understand where it says in here
that it only applies to single family
homes it doesn't it but we're talking
about okay let's think about the um the
labor department right they're going to
not be inspecting in the woods they're
going to be inspecting within the
curtilage of a building right so it it
doesn't say single family homes but
where in the world with the labor
partment I'm just I'm
just to single family homes is all I
don't want to go back to the labor
department okay
it doesn't say single family homes but
the labor Department's concerns again
would only apply to within the curtilage
of a building anyway representative
n so uh I remember that that part of the
conversation I remember that the person
who is um a representative of the labor
department was the person to come here
but that it it may apply to a variety of
other um people who could be considered
a government agent which I think would
probably include the uh Planning
Commission but um the way that I read
this uh you know it also says it says
notwithstanding ing any other provision
of law um so I think if there you know
are Provisions that allow for the
planning department or you know
inspections and things like that that
would be allowed um and then also um
upon entering private land a government
uh agent shall immediately notify land
over ly or occupant if notice can
reasonably be be made and so it kind it
does allow for a little bit of breathing
room but um but it's also uh extending
the the same rights as your your home to
your property thank you representative
new I like your explanation much better
than mine um to representative Jam's
point if there's a statute that says the
planning board can go on property this
is notwithstanding so they can do it um
and that would also apply to um
assessors and anyone else in who in
statute already has the authority to go
on a property for whatever government
business this wouldn't apply to them
they are Exempted because of another
statute and frankly we could write other
statutes in the future and they would
Trump this because it says other
statutes not withstanding so further
discussion representative here gther
okay so why were you removing five I
would believe that you would want that
document representative Manion please
thank you Mr chair so that's already in
statute so to add it's already in the
body camera statute that anytime you're
performing a law enforcement function it
shall be recorded So to have it in every
other statute uh if you add it to
investigations or murder whatever kind
of other you can't add body cameras to
every statute there's a statute
governing it already so there's no need
to to double up on
it so because it's removed doesn't mean
it's not happening it just means it's
already covered somewhere else in other
words the statue that specifically
covers body cameras already requires
them to turn them on when they're
performing law enforcement functions so
it would be redundant to have it in here
because then we might as well put body
cameras in every statute that the police
are involved with instead of do that we
put it in one body C statute is that
right represent Manu you did better than
I did thank you thank you representative
Muse I think what we have here is your
your classic uh bill in search of a
problem um the person who gave the most
testimony to public hearing was from an
outof State advocacy organization who
basically admitted to the fact that he's
made passing bills like this his life's
work in other states uh we didn't hear
from a single property owner who was AG
grieved in a situation like this we also
um heard from police officers that
essentially police officers in New
Hampshire are actually trained to
respect other people's property when
they see that property is posted they
contact the property owner um I'm you
know I think bills like this are always
interested is intellectual exercises um
but the fact is is you know with 19
bills on the calendar today I I think
it's important that we focus on the ones
that actually are going to solve
problems uh and I'm just not sure that I
see your problem here that needs to be
solved thank you thank you I would um I
would say that um the vast majority of
lobbyists we see are either connected to
or part of an outof State quote unquote
organization and they often write
legislation for legislators so I will
not use that to detract from any bill
that's before us um with regard to not
hearing from Property Owners um one um I
believe several other people in here are
one um and I I I don't want them on my
property um and whether or not it's
happening I guess we don't we don't
leave it to the police um to Boy Scout
swear that they're going to do things
that we think they should that's why we
have the Constitution and um to keep
them in line and we also have numerous
laws that limit what they can do so um I
did find cases where it's happening and
sometimes we it may not be happening
every day but we do a lot of
prophylactic bills and um I think that
this is one of them but we agree to
disagree um any further discussion yep
representative here gath um just looking
at some of my notes from that day and um
I think it was Chief Walch from Ry that
testified yes and he also talked about
you know they believe that the home is
Al Castle
and um the training at the Academy when
in doubt get a
warrant um he also mentioned that
um the warrant is standard in most
cases they get yearly an updated
training and they actually were working
on the state certification which would
say that they would have to have warrant
um warrants in some cases um when
yeah um so if this is
already I guess cified in their training
at the
Academy I would just want to know why do
we need that Bill repr Wheeler Mr
chairman um I I hear the points made by
uh representative goth and
representative Muse about training and
how this is already the police are
already train Tred to protect property
rights I made the same point to Chief
Walsh when he was here and he didn't uh
satisfactorily answer my question I said
well you're doing a great job in Rye
right now you've got a great Chief there
they've got it we've got director skippa
he's doing a great job training what's
to say 10 20 years down the line there
is less of a great director of police
standards and training or less of a
great chief of police in Ry uh that
person might not train their officers to
respect property rights as much and
legislation statute like this would make
it so that it's codified into law by the
legislature that people have a right to
their property if it's posted then
people can't go on it whether it's the
state whether it's Hunters whether it's
anybody if it says no trespassing then
people cannot trespass and I guess I I
just have to make the point because we
hear it all the time in this committee
we cannot rely on the training standards
of an administrative agency um you know
whether it's the racial profiling bill
or anything else we we hear all the time
that it's codified into training but
it's not happening and I think it's
important sometimes for the legislature
to take action to codify some
administrative action for that agency
and that's what this does thank you
represent Manion you good um
representative
Newman yeah I have a problem with this
La I feel that it's it we are already
have a Supreme Court decision that says
you're in an open field a big large area
away from any any residence or whatever
you're talking
about um that th this bill requires that
you can get the consent all the time in
it's section
uh four says unless entering on the land
pursuant to the consent or ex
exent circumstances a government agent
shall show the so show the search
warrant authorizing entry into to the
property owner um and it all and it and
it starts to use the word instead of
secured premises it uses private land
and it doesn't have a definition for
private land so I assume that means any
any land that that land owner was so I
think it's too broad I think it violates
an already existing us constitutional
law that says that you have no right to
privacy in an open field so I'm going to
vote against this law thank you thank
you um for clarification on open field
open field is kind of a catch-all word
it doesn't necessarily mean what you
feel you picture is you know the fields
of barley it's not that it it just means
the property that is not the curtilage
so I I own 6 acres and I get a pool and
probably 20 ft beyond that it's no
longer the curtilage um when I'm mowing
it sometimes it feels like an open field
but it's just my lawn and Beyond that's
a couple acres of woods also not an open
field but that's considered the open
field so that's it's not a
constitutional law it's interpretation
of the Constitution and we can't stop
federal agents with this law they can
ignore it and they can say Open Fields
until there's a federal law but our
state law enforcement officers would
have to honor this and not go into my
Open Fields um but your point is well
taken and we agree to disagree um
representative
Pratt well I'm a land owner and I'm also
in favor of this law anybody that wants
to leave their property open for
everybody to walk on just doesn't have
to put the signs up all this does is it
makes it clearer that if you put a no
trespassing sign up no means no no
trespassing means no trespassing it's
all this bill does if you don't want
that to happen if you want people to be
able to walk across your property
anytime they want you just don't put the
signs up simple as that thank you I I
would assume that you could even post
your property no law enforcement if if
that's what you wanted to post it um we
are very uh like I said are are no
trespass laws are very uh complicated um
with that I would ask the clerk to call
the role the motion on the floor is of
to pass with Amendment no it's I'm sorry
this is the amendment um the motion is
to adopt the
amendment Vice chair roads yes
representative Pratt yes representative
scitec representative
pu uh yes representative jandrin yes
representative Manion yes representative
re yes representative Lynn yes
representative tzar yes representative
Harry gther yes representative Muse yes
representative Balden yes representative
Bradley yes representative Murphy yes
representative Newman reluctantly it
does improve the bill I yes uh the clerk
votes yes representative Newell yes
representative cik yes representative
wheeler yay chairman Roy jot chess 20 20
the amendment is adopted I make a motion
of ought to pass with Amendment second
second by representative rhods um unless
anyone has anything significant to add I
think we pretty much discussed the whole
thing seeing none um I would ask the
clerk to call the role the motion is
ought to pass with
Amendment Vice chair roads yes
representative Pratt yes representative
scitec representative pu yes
representative janen yes representative
Manion yes representative Reed yes
representative Lynn yes representative
tenar yes representative Harry gther no
representative muse no representative
Balden yes representative Bradley yes
representative Murphy no representative
Newman no the clerk votes yes
representative Newell yes Representative
celik no representative wheeler yay
chairman Roy chotes yes 155 155 this
will not go on consent um
I'll adjust this after but I'll say it
now too we're all off next week but um I
need the reports be it pro or against no
later than Tuesday because I have to go
into the clerk's office by Wednesday
with that I close the executive session
and we will meet back here at 1:15 we
hour
I'm opening the executive session on
House Bill 1214 and I recognize
representative rhods to make a motion
thank you Mr chairman I make a motion
to I House Bill
second representative
PR oh would you like to speak to your
motion representative rhods sure so I do
recognize the well I think I do
understand the the intention of the
sponsor with this bill um there are
already rest restorative justice
programs in in the state I I know for
fact I am on one for the the county um
they actually work quite well
um basically if a if a minor commits a
crime they have the option to the judge
can say hey look we're going to you know
have you go this path um kind of try to
write you're wrong and then when the
program is complete the charges are
never filed they just they they
disappear
um I was a little bit confused because
there already is something in existence
I was a little conf confused on the
whole purpose of this um but I also
think that you know you have the option
to go meet with your District Attorney's
Office you can meet with your local
police departments I just don't think we
have to have a a law that gives you the
right to do that because everything that
is wanted to be done can can already be
done without a law to do it
representative Pro would you like to
speak to your
second no I think she covered that quite
well thank you okay I I just like to
start by I do want to point out that um
it's not only a restorative justice but
it was the hate crimes portion that the
sponsor and I'm sure she's going to tell
us um was interested in um the reason
and probably the majority if not the
entire reason that I I'm not in favor of
this is isn't anything to do so much
with the subject matter as um we've
heard from a speaker and the clerk um
about these committees and commissions
and um we are we have so many of them
that um are because once we do this it's
on the law forever um the committee or
commission will expire obviously because
it's a committee they only have till
September to come up with some kind of
report um but the the marching orders
we've kind of gotten is unless it's
absolutely necessary um if it can't be
done some other way we shouldn't be
doing new committees or commissions I
feel like this is an important topic
with regard to the hate crimes and
juveniles a lot of them are getting
caught up in this but I I don't feel we
need to codify it and and I think we can
do a lot of work on on ourselves we can
figure stuff out and come up with ideas
without putting in statute um again
though that's just one one person's
opinion and I'm going to uh open it for
discussion and I know without even
talk oh sure
okay sure come on and come up yeah
representative new and I saw you out of
the corner of my represent Muse thank
you um I think uh you know Point well
taken I guess about the Committees and
and commissions and things like that
what it really comes down to I guess is
how you prioritize it right and and what
you think is really important I do
understand especially because um uh
because uh we are in the same uh County
that this is happening in our County um
one thing that I have heard in in you
know about the the success in in our
school system and and uh in our County
and things like that um um is that it
has been helpful um and I think that you
know what we do here is not just for our
own counties although we do that as well
um but you know we try to say hey this
is working really well in in this County
maybe we can take that information we
can um you know see what's happening in
other counties and and really come up
with something that um is helpful on a
state level so I feel like this is still
very much worth doing um you know even
if we are busy I think we should make it
a priority so thank you forther
discussion representative wheeler
thank you Mr chairman um I'm going to be
voting against the itl motion I
appreciate uh the clerk's position on
committees and study committees and
things like that um this is I feel is an
important uh committee to move forward
and and I'm sure um knowing how
passionately representative selig feels
about this and how passionately other
Representatives feel that there would be
membership for this committee um so I
I'm going to support this uh I think
that even even if it fails though that
there would be a way to move forward
with one of the existing commissions or
committees that exist uh
already are given statute
statutory uh charge from us um to have
them look at Best Practices for
juveniles uh getting these charges and
going into juvenile uh prison I'm saying
even if this bill fails or comes out
1010 which it seems like it might that
they're I think is a consensus that
there might be a
good it could be a good impetus to move
forward to start looking at how we can
deal with this issue which seems to be
one thank you good points representative
um
Muse yeah so we're we're at a point
where where hate crimes are basically On
The Rise uh in New Hampshire and
unfortunately a fair number of the
people uh who are being apprehended for
those crimes when they are apprehended
are juveniles and um I think one of the
things that I that we try to do in our
criminal justice system is to put young
people like that into a position where
they can more effectively begin to make
decisions and do things that can kind of
turn their lives around um and I think
we've all read instances of people who
were involved with hate groups when they
were young and had different experiences
and wound up feeling a you know feeling
a different way um you know to me if if
if we didn't have the State Attorney
General's office you know just recently
beefing up its ha hate crime division um
if if we if we didn't actually have a an
issue in New Hampshire with it um I I
think I'd agree with you I'm I'm not a
big fan of creating study committees for
the stake of creating study committees
um but you know this is an example of
where
you know an area where I I think people
who have a little bit of experience with
the law and I would consider most of us
as having a little bit of experience can
draw in people with a lot more
experience and maybe come up with some
solutions that could put us in a better
place um and uh you know that's why I I
I like the bill when uh representative
Cel uh put it forward and and why I
support
it thank
you pres selig and and could you could
you explain I know we've already gone
over just explain what the committee
would do thank you so um my motivation
for the committee is really the
combination of I think being a former
teacher and teaching High School level
students uh being a parent of teenagers
and um knowing how easy it is for
teenagers to be swayed by their peers to
make core choices at times choices that
in uh moments of better thinking and
being their best selves they wouldn't
choose to make but um sometimes those
impulsive actions have really serious
consequences and um I was thinking about
that a lot over the summer at the same
time as there were a number of hate
crimes increasing across the state um as
well as within my own child's uh high
school there were a number of of
significant incidents in in sorry my St
in
instances um getting my out is getting
trickier um so thinking about all of
those things and then at the same time I
was reading about the success of the
Teen Court programs in Maryland which
are not restorative justice programs
designed by adults for for teens but
programs designed by teens for teens um
where they were ultimately coming up
with models that were um had a 90 4%
success rate in many cases um so very
very few kids were ending up coming back
into needing additional situations and
thinking was there a way to put together
something like the Teen Court program
which no longer exists in New Hampshire
and trying to figure out why it doesn't
exist is it a matter of we don't have
the resources for it or is it a matter
of truly it doesn't work here and and
nobody could answer that for me when I
made those initial calls so trying to
figure that out we have in some counties
we have youth diversion programs but not
in every County in some districts we do
in others we don't so trying to think
about okay we've got all these dispar
pieces how can we put it all together to
make sense out of it in a way because my
ultimate goal is not to have kids end up
in the judicial system at all but to
help them learn why it is they're doing
what they're doing so that they'll make
better choices in the future and and
ideally break the cycle right break it
completely so that rather than someone
going into say a juvenile detention
center and then aligning themselves with
people with misguided hateful ideas and
coming out of that and being more likely
to end up in the adult judicial system
that we get them out of it completely
and maybe the next time their friends
say hey let's go do this really stupid
act they're like no we shouldn't do that
let me tell you what I learned you
really should we don't want to do that
so that's where my motivation came from
but trying to figure out how to put all
those pieces together into something
meaningful there were so many different
partners I spoke to and they're like oh
it's a great idea you could try this or
you could try this and so just trying to
bring people together so we could make
something sensible out of it
at the same time who who's on your
committee who's on my who I yeah no who
who would be on it in the bill I know
the copy in front of me I'm sorry I'm
all disassembled
here so um uh representative Alicia Greg
from Hillsboro County I reached out to I
spoke to obviously no no no I I mean who
members of the House oh who is the
makeup of the committee it's a total of
um
Senate uh three members of the House of
Representatives and one member of the
Senate and then the other outside people
appointed to it or just no because it's
a study committee so you can't right
require them I did have um a long
conversation with
um with um Sean Lock from um the
Attorney General's office um and when he
first called me he was very skeptical of
my bringing this forward and at the end
he said it was a conversation he'd like
to be part of and he he would want his
office to get involved in that we've had
some additional conversations and then
right before we went to hearing on this
his Department went from him to like
four people and so I didn't hear back
from him because I'm pretty sure he was
trying to figure out how to supervise
his three new people in grow his newly
growing Department um I also spoke to
Tom bardi um who's now uh in the
Attorney General's office he was very
involved in creating restorative justice
programs in straford County before he
moved to the uh State's attorne
attorney's office so um and with the
ACLU as well and their support um and I
spoke to someone from restorative
justice I just don't have their name at
the top of my head and do you feel like
you could accomplish what you want to
accomplish in three months um I feel
like we could accomplish a lot we might
not accomplish everything but we might
be able to come up with some answers in
some ways that would be
meaningful um representative Balden oh
excuse me no representative Muse did you
have your hand up or did you already
speak you already spoke representative
Bolton
so it sounds like instead of deciding on
your own as a lawmaker how to solve this
problem you're just suggesting that time
be spent by a committee of people
figuring out how to solve this problem I
I respect that I think it's um
refreshing for a New Hampshire state
representative to not think they have
all the
answers yeah to can I could my I know I
was thinking about changing my vote
until she said that so oh I mean my my
idea my idea is really to look at what's
best practices for all kids that it's
not a partisan issue it's really an
issue just of how do we figure out
something that's going to best serve the
kids across the state and hopefully also
if we can avoid having them end up in
any form of the judicial system save us
money represent Reed thank you Mr
chairman this um peer-led group where
would this take place would it be at at
the Department of Corrections would it
be at a school would it be at a
community center where do you envision
this taking place that's a great
question and why I need a study
committee so we can look at all the
different possibilities and what would
actually work for some of these things I
don't even know if it would still work
in the state I know it's working in
other states and so again there was one
in marac but there wasn't in any other
part of the state and I don't know they
said it disbanded in part because of the
um pandemic and whether it couldn't be
restarted or whether it's just that
there's not the funds I don't know the
answers and the people I reached out to
point follow up um I think it's a great
idea I just would not want to see it
with everything going on in schools
right now I'd rather see I would like to
see something like that in a different
setting so that they can focus on
academics get more back on track in the
schools so what they learn that the
committee should be extra
right this this wouldn't be a school
based thing this would be a study
committee to figure out how to deal with
these issues and if you would like to be
on the study committee I'm sure that can
be arranged with the speaker with your
support all right so um given a
discussion um I'm inclined to to change
my position so I'm going to tell um my
members you can vote however you want um
if you're inclined to
support um I would uh entertain uh
removal of the itl motion just to save
us from doing two different votes if you
wish to move forward that's obviously
you're right and we can have that vote
too who made the motion I didn't say one
sure absolutely so um if if I may this
is uh uh to representative selig
the so what I was what I was trying to
say is that the restorative justice
program and just the in general I guess
if I want to say the redirection program
program that that we have at the county
level you would probably be welcome to
join us for for one of those um and I
think it would probably answer a lot of
questions you have and maybe help with
the direction that you're that you're
trying to go
so that's kind of what I was getting at
is
that a lot of what you're trying to
accomplish could be
answered could be answered with that
without necessarily having to have it
put into law that's that's what I was
trying to get at it might answer a lot
of the questions that you have so that's
that was
that
repres I want very much to be wrong I
want this to work but I don't believe it
I would like to see the
results because I see
these life's cadavers walking the
hallways and I don't know how you reach
them if I ask them for a pass I'm going
to get a
fight and for every legislator I see
who's recovered from drugs and has come
back and leading a wonderful life
there's and I'm not I shouldn't have
used wonderful letter um there
are many who I don't I don't know the
numbers who've committed suicide who've
lost their lives and to Pivot this on
the fact that we may Rescue of a
precious
few I want to be wrong but I just don't
I don't I if I get out voted that's
great I want I want I want to lose I or
I want you to succeed but I don't I'm I
guess I'm a little bit jaist I don't
think we approach this and I'll finish
with this from the mentality of
irrational adults who know best who who
would not you don't even think about
littering okay how do you can transmit
those
values to somebody who's a vict who
traffics and hate crimes who has
absolutely no interest in society
that this is I I I realize I'm sort of
more more jaundice than I should be but
that's how I that's my life's experience
and how I'm approaching this thank you
thank you uh representative scitech and
we are great greatly concerned about
your liver um representative sing so
again I'm not thinking I'm going to
solve everything with this um they're
going to be the people like our friend
who likes to send us letters um on a
regular basis who are going to continue
to be full of hate for anyone who isn't
just like he is but with kids more times
than not it's because they've been
they've gone down a rabbit hole and if
you can get them the right ladder to get
them back out of that rabbit hole you
can avoid a lot of problems and if we
can catch them early and identify things
and so again the goal of this is really
to look at what do we have that is
working and I hope we have more programs
working than it appears from where I sit
but what's working what what can we be
doing better and and what are the other
options so maybe there are other things
but again my goal is in having a study
group is to bring together constituents
from different angles to try to figure
that out collaboratively so that maybe
you'll be put out of business as a bale
commissioner at least in relation to
this crime okay now you're getting crazy
um you had me until you went off the
real um all right so there's of
hands representative Newman don't snatch
Victory from the mouth of no I'm just
thinking I never try to snatch Victory
but I don't a lot of times I get too
many
defeats I just think that this is a good
thing we've been to drug court and we
saw how much they thought that was a
valuable thing to do because it kept
somebody out of the criminal justice
system and I'd like to see that
accomplished and this might be the
opportunity to take a little bit of
effort that might get us to understand
whether or not we could do that with
this this doesn't make a law I mean it
something we ought to I think we should
follow I I I I agree I mean it doesn't
cost anything but time and and um just
to be clear clear before anyone makes
any or removes any
motions anyone who worked on the bill
last summer is probably not going to
want to be on this I'm going hunting I
don't care what study committee I'm not
being part of it um so representative um
rhods would you um entertain which are
on your
motion I will withdraw it hoping that
someone else makes it and writes the
report um who made the second that would
be me and I will withdraw my second okay
um so I recognize representative sing
for a motion I move OTP for
1214 second by representative
wheeler um we've had discussion
um it's um it is what it is and you read
forward you're against it um vote how
you want and I would ask the to call the
role and one more time I'm not going to
be on the study
committee Vice chair roads yes
representative
Pratt yes representative
scitec you can say yes you know
representative PR yes Representative
jandrin no representative Manion yes
representative Reed yes representative
Lynn yes representative tenar yes
representative Harry
gther representative Muse yes
representative balen yes representative
Bradley yes representative Murphy yes
representative Newman
yes the clerk votes yes representative
Newell yes representative celik
absolutely representative wheeler yay
chairman Roy chair yes 182 182 is there
an objection to
consent see none I he by close the
executive
session thank you and you're welcome
send you the bill in the morning yeah
with that we move on
to
um huh no no one objected it going on
con relative to protective custody uh I
hereby open executive session on House
Bill
1270 guys 1270 and I
recognize
motion
what yeah Mr chairman i' defer to the
person that has the amend for the bill
to to make motion who is who has the mo
the amendment oh it's you okay um
recognize represent
no hello um trying to pull it up since
the
amendment um changes things a little bit
0851 and um the reason for the amendment
let me just talk a little bit about kind
of what the reason for the bill was in
the first first place um the reason for
the bill was because people who were
being brought in under protective
custody um were uh there was some
um lack of resources at the end of the
day right so there were not the
resources to be able to satisfy the law
in the way that it's stated statutorily
and so this was kind of a solution to
saying we don't necessarily always have
a medical professional on staff um as
was testified to um thoroughly um there
may maybe kind of during business hours
Monday to Friday 9 to 5 that type of
thing um but on the weekend there's a
lot less of um uh it's it's there isn't
the Staffing to be able to do this at a
correctional correctional facility and
so the idea of doing this bill was uh uh
was to try and get everyone into
compliance um since it was required um
that someone who is uh being held in
protective custody and they were going
to be held at the local jail or in the
correctional facility um
so this was uh bringing them into
compliance since the liability would be
on them so we had a lot of discussion uh
when we heard about the bill um as it
was introduced um about
um uh problems throughout so anyway but
but what this bill what this amendment
aims to do is just to really get at the
heart of what the issue was why this
bill was brought in the first place to
get to uh to to resolve the issue that
it was trying to resolve in the first
place and so what it does is it removes
two things they they say the same thing
in different parts of the law um no
person shall be lodged in a local jail
or County Correctional Facility under
paragraph 2 unless the person um in
charge of the the facility immediately
upon uh lodging said person in
protective custody contacts that uh a
designated drug counselor a clinical
staff person of an approved drug
treatment program with
detoxification um capabilities or a
professional medical staff person at a
licensed General Hospital emergency room
to determine what that uh whether said
person is in indeed uh incapacitated if
and only if none of the forgoing is
available such medical or clinical
determination shall be made by a
registered nurse or registered emergency
medical technician on the staff of the
Detention Facility so there there is no
um outside of essentially business hours
there is no uh registered nurse or uh
registered emergency medical um
technician at the facility um outside of
essentially business hours so on the
weekend and things like that so if
somebody's brought in for protective
custody then it becomes okay who is the
liability on is it on the officer who is
bringing it to uh bringing this person
um to the facility or is it on the
facility once they get there and so it's
created some kind of back and forth
about um who would who would essentially
be liable for that and what we've had is
we've had people being turned away um
from Correctional Facilities because
they do not have a person on staff to be
able to do that so it's a matter of
whose judgment it is so the sponsor
brought this amendment um representative
Shapiro brought this amendment so that
he could um kind of cut away all of the
other things and still try to address
the essential problem that was happening
in the first place so taking out that
section of law um kind of alleviates the
liability did I do a terrible job of
explaining that CU I feel like I'm
guys if we could just um just have you
know what um I'd like uh 10 minutes I I
want to read the actual statute so I can
bump it up against the amendment um
minutes
e
we are back
on and it's now discuss continued
discussion on the amendment um last
person who spoke I believe was
representative uh n um anyone else
wishing to speak on the
amendment very quickly so basically the
amendment repeals the whole bill and
just replaces it with these three
lines
no a new section of law if I'm not
mistaken
um repeal the statute doesn't say repeal
the the amendment it says amend the bill
by replacing everything after the enact
all after the enacting Clause with the
following so it repeals everything else
that was in the draft except for this
yes please
okay doesn't look like we need help does
it Kate Horan New Hampshire Association
of counties so this isn't amending the
bill this is this amendment amends the
statute and only takes out the piece
that says we have to immediately
evaluate someone when they are in the
correctional facility because if they
are so intoxicated that they cannot form
sentences regardless of whether or not I
have medical staff on board I can't
evaluate them or counsel them about you
know getting getting services that is
all this bill does it takes out the
concerns of the police Chiefs and the
sheriffs um so it just focuses on
removing that section of law so if
you're looking at just the amendment you
can forget the bill and just look at
current
statute
yes yeah we seem to have a we seem to
have a um okay so let's just all go
through it together
class repeal the following are repealed
RSA
1725 um Roman three relative to contact
requirements regarding incapacity
IND RSA 172 B3 relative to contact
requirements incapacity taken in EV so
amend the bill by replacing all after
the enacting Clause what is the enacting
the enacting Clause Mr chairman says
being enacted by the Senate and House of
Representative and general court
convened that's the enacting Clause so
replaced are all gone it yeah it says
after the enacting Clause so it's the
the wording of the bill just no I'm okay
takes it all
away except for those two things well
bust my buttons twice today I'm going to
change my my mind um all right so having
said that everything I just told
everyone in the room that we don't talk
about is is
gone no that's gone that that wipes all
that out making sure yeah that actually
took a bill that in my opinion was not
so good and fixed some law that was
already bad um so what's not to like
um oh so everything we've everything
we've just discussed however is um
immaterial until I get a second to the
adoption of the amendment you move
to oh okay all right
good yeah got it okay
so just I want to State it for all the
members the bill that we had is now for
the most part except for being enacted
by the house gone this new bill strikes
out the two places in law where it said
that they had to do a medical evaluation
on somebody the moment they arrived for
protective custody
only obviously we heard from law
enforcement if someone's got an obvious
injury they're getting them treated um
they're calling an ambulance or what
have you they're not bringing them all
broken to the jail and if the jail sees
they're all broken they're calling an
ambulance I mean in other words no one's
getting tucked away with obvious
injuries that they're only can be held
for a maximum 24 hours so having someone
evaluated to talk about um you know
their their absess Moler or whatever
else irrelevant they most of them don't
stay the 24 hours somebody comes and
gets them I think this saves our
counties a lot of money it doesn't put
anybody in any risk um I'm not seeing
the downsides any further discussion
representative Murray thank you Mr chair
um my only concern is if we're saying an
evaluation doesn't need to be done if
someone is brought in um um you know on
drugs or something and they're not
evaluated is there not a possibility of
them going into an overdose wall in a
cell or like some other medical
emergency that could happen because they
were not evaluated upon entry it is my
understanding that people that are in
protective custody are monitored um the
entire time they're there so it's not
like normal incarcerated guests who are
just you know here's your celce in the
morning the people that are in PC are
monitored um all night long because
because of the fact they're there
because they are intoxicated um so if
they were to example OD and fall out I
would imagine within moment somebody
would be there with our can and they'd
be calling the wagon to come get them
representative Reed thank you Mr
chairman um I don't understand I mean it
just seems to me that law enforcement
has a good handle on this and they've
been dealing with these situations for a
long time so why are we presenting a
bill I don't feel is necessary be happy
to tell you please yeah so if you look
at the statute the protective custody
statute the problem we've had is at some
point in the past somebody put in there
to protect people I would assume from
being put into protective custody who
didn't need it that they would be
medically evaluated for the sole purpose
if you read the statue to ensure they
are indeed
incapacitated um times have advanced um
now there's no way that the people in
the jail and the cops are all going to
be in and put a sober person in there
nobody wants at risk they've invented
lawyers recently so what it's done is
remained in statute and now they're
starting to play Hot Potato with human
beings well we don't want to hold them
well we don't want to hold them U it's
it's horrible it's calling staffing
issues it's causing so the original bill
I did not like because it was huge
ponderous this fixes the law which is
really what needed to be done in my
opinion further discussion and as I
understand it is that oh without
removing these pieces
somebody has to evaluate them formally
yes right whether it's a drug counselor
or whatever that may not be on staff so
that removes that piece because I would
like to think law enforcement
Correctional and whoever can after a
little bit of experience can determine
whether somebody needs to be sent to the
hospital or they're all set to stay here
so they don't need some uh person with
alphabets after their name to get called
in or whatever to say
that thank you and again I'd point out
the existing statute that calls for this
eval is not for their health it's only
to see if they're intoxicated so I think
that to your point law enforcement knows
if someone's intoxicated and so does the
jail uh hold on representative Murray
Murphy did you have something uh thank
you yes I I just want to see um in my
notes I look back and it and um it seems
that section three of 172 B3 was the
biggest concern of the superintendent of
Chester County Department of Corrections
and that Captain Dustin parin agreed
that taking that section out would not
create any negative impacts so there was
agreement on on that yes I I agree I
believe the superintendent said if
you're not going to do anything else at
least do that then we're going to at
least do that representative s just to
clarify y um but this this type of
incapacitation is both drug related as
well as alcohol related correct I just
yes thank you very yeah
um
yes further
discussion represent minion thank you
this is the ghost Corner over here
so yeah I agree so if you get somebody
that they're going to evaluate and they
don't have somebody on staff it's two in
the morning because that's when most
people are drinking heavily or people I
know anyways um and they got to call
somebody in that could take two three
four hours to get somebody to come in
that person could be soed up by then so
it really I mean it's really a mood
point so I agree that moving these
sections would be beneficial and in that
time while whoever it is is coming from
wherever they're coming to do this
someone can come and pick them up and
they're gone and the whole exercise was
a waste of time and money and it just
doesn't make any sense okay so the
motion um is to adopt the amendment R by
representative new um I would ask the C
to call the role on the adoption of the
amendment which I
like Vice chair roads yes representative
Pratt
yes representative scitec yes
representative PR yes please
representative Janan yes representative
Manion yes representative Reed yes
representative Lynn yes representative
tensar yes representative Harriet
gaite yes representative Muse yes
representative Balden yes representative
Bradley yes representative Murphy yes
representative
Newman yes the clerk votes yes
representative Newell yes representative
celik yes representative wheeler yay
chairman Roy chair votes yes 20 20 um
the mo the amendment is adopted I would
recognize representative new to make a
motion make a motion for a to pass with
Amendment Harry gather no Murphy Oh
represent
Murphy and any further
discussion seeing none I would ask to
call the role motions ought to pass as
amended Vice chair roads yes
representative Pratt yes representative
scitec representative PR yes
representative
Janan yes representative Manion yes
representative Reed yes representative
Lynn yes representative tenar yes
representative Harry gther yes
representative Muse yes representative
Balden yes representative Bradley yes
representative Murphy yes representative
Newman yes the clerk votes yes
representative Newell yes representative
yes representative wheeler yay chairman
Roy chair yes 20 20 the um bill passes
unanimously no any objection to consent
seeing none It Go on consent executive
session is closed I hereby open the
executive session on House Bill 1276 and
I recognize representative Manion to
make a
motion um thank you Mr chair I make a
motion of uh a
pass seconded by anyone sure I'll second
that thank you would you like to speak
to your motion represent man yes thank
you Mr chair so this is a bill that we
passed last year um repealing
these uh prohibition against these
weapons I wouldn't do it for those that
are under 18 just 18 and over um these
are these are weapons that can be you
could you could possess if you're a
hunter you can possess if you're law
enforcement but the general public
cannot possess them
and a lot of these are Antiquated
weapons and a lot of people have them
for desktop type of uh knickknacks and
stuff so um I think it's time we we pass
this repel
that thank you representative um for
like speak your second yes
so you know they talk about all their
weapons and what have you but they are
less than lethal weapons so if people
can carry a firearm now they have an
option if they're somebody attacks them
they can fend them off with these if
they happen to be carrying them but like
the you know the rep said most people
don't carry these anymore they're just
knickknacks and you know history things
of days gone by you know I'm older than
dirt so I kind of remember them figed i'
beat that I've heard that one
before thank you uh representative
I'm reading directly from the
constitution of the State of New
Hampshire article 2A the bearing of arms
all persons have the right to keep and
bear arms in defense of themselves their
families their property and the state if
these items are used in a defensive
posture we have that right however if
they use it in an offensive way it's
already a crime so I definitely support
the
OTP thank you um further discussion
anyone else representative wheeler on
the melee weapons well I was going to
call it the Brass Monkey I don't know
but is the rest of us you are now older
than dirt there you
go representative Newman says that my
brain is older than dirt so I don't know
I was consistent with that I support the
OTP on this I think it's silly to ban
these devices these weapons when the
police are able to use them when Hunters
are able to use them and for the lay
person on the street I mean how do you
know if someone's got a hunting license
to be able to carry these weapons so if
you're
being you know I don't know if you're
trying to attack somebody and they pull
out brass knuckles how do you know that
that's not in violation of the section
they could have a hunting license it
could be legal so I just think you know
we have a some of us are so adverse to
what could potentially come from these
weapons that were were against the bill
but I think that the you know obviously
no one wants to see somebody get beaten
up by a a a brass knuckle or a slungshot
or whatever the third thing is I don't
know but um fact of the matter is people
have a right to own these weapons and
you know while it's not good it's not
great that people get attacked people
have a right to defend themselves on the
streets and I think of a woman who you
know might not want to carry a gun and
you know wants to carry some brass
knuckles that same woman could pick up a
rock from the street and just as deadly
as the brass knuckles so if we're
concerned about deadliness we should ban
rocks but we all know how silly that is
so I I support the OTP motion on this
and uh yeah as representative man said
these are are essentially neck knacks
these days so we're just legalizing a
collector's item and I think that's a
worthwhile thing to do um you what you
said actually reminded me of a a
commercial I saw not too long ago for a
product for women I think it was called
The Claw and it was um something they
could hold that had like a cat's claw so
they could if an attacker came out I
mean it's the same kind of concept
somebody who's smaller and can get rid
of somebody who's trying to cost them as
they get in their car or what have you
um rep you do represent Manion
see no you did have your hand up I saw
he was doing the ra
scitec represents uh
music yeah I I find it kind of
incredible that a committee that is
charged with criminal justice and Public
Safety is poised to pass a bill that
would actually make it easier for one
human being to beat another human being
to death um I think if you if you look
at the kinds of injuries that these uh
you know that these that these weapons
cause um they're essentially a force
multiplier um uh the injuries that they
cause are things like fractured orbital
bones broken teeth they require plastic
surgery in some cases people don't
recover uh when they're beaten by people
who are using these weapons which is one
of the reasons why we currently ban them
under state law we don't necessarily
want people with these weapons in bars
and public gathering places we don't
want them in schools and the fact that
we're uh prohibiting uh selling and
distributing them under this particular
bill to people uh age 18 and under
doesn't necessarily keep them out of our
schools uh because we actually let
people go to 18 and over representative
we we actually we actually allow people
uh uh who are 18 and over to attend our
high
schools um so um I have been against
this one uh in its Forum last year I
continue to be against it uh I don't
think it's good public policy from a
public safety standpoint and I will
oppose
it thank you I would um I would Hazard
to say that I've seen the results um of
the damage of some of these weapons and
I've also seen the results of uh on a
woman of being forcibly raped and I
would um I'd Advocate the the person who
did it get the brass knuckles before she
gets
raped further discussion seeing none up
representative
through so that was kind of going to be
my point is
that that someone is okay leaving a
woman defenseless or anybody defenseless
to be attacked by someone
else is unacceptable to me
right I'm not just going to say yeah
okay it's okay if somebody attacks you
if somebody chooses to attack me I'm
going to defend
myself and if they get injured well
that's too bad because they made the
decision to attack me first not that I
attack them first but I'm going to
defend myself with whatever I
lethal not a gun so much the better that
person will probably
survive but if I my only option is a
firearm they probably will not
survive so you're taking away my
chance to do less than lethal Force I
don't think that's right at
all I have a question um and
representative um use actually made me
think of
it would this allow a let's say a senior
in high school to bring these into
school I'd like to know
that Mr chair sure the school can make a
policy there are no weapons in school
well that's not necessarily true because
schools we um we we carry we can carry
guns to vote at a school but would it be
different though because they're
actually school children they're a
student and they so they have to follow
the school policy yeah you're voting is
not a school voting okay I just want to
be clear I'm not I would not be in favor
of students carrying these around the
halls of the school
representative me first in
representative Eric G thank you a couple
of things so this being referred to as
an offensive weapon is is is wrong
because it's a defensive weapon anything
can be an offensive weapon but this goes
back to the old saying that if just
because it's illegal doesn't mean the
person who wants to go out and use it as
an offensive weapon is going to care
they're not going to say oh I can't
carry a brass knuckle so I'll have to
grab a stick on the way over there
they're going to use it so this is all
this is doing is preventing those people
women who don't who don't want to carry
a gun they're afraid of carrying a gun
but they have some sort of defense and
if they get if the person who attacks my
it Katherine I actually agree with
everything that um representative Muse
said and I do have a true concern for
the school because keep in mind here in
this state 24 years old you can still be
in high
school yeah I agree um but the point was
made it's corly that if the school has a
policy then the students have to follow
it they they wouldn't be able to get out
of it with
this it's not considered a weapon when
you take it out it's a weapon
now she mentioned something it's a
weapon it's a weapon but a gun's
considered a weapon I'm not talking
about a gun we're talking I understand
that but that's that's legal to carry
yeah and that's a weapon so school
doesn't mean it's a weapon right it's
not a weapon it's still a weapon yeah
the school can say that they don't have
they can just specific specifically say
no no brass knuckles no nothing you
can't I think they already do most of
them represent wheeler thank you Mr
chairman and I also just have to say
this doesn't increase the prevalence of
brass knuckles they're not going to be a
million more brass knuckles because we
passed this bill have all of us oh there
maybe we will maybe maybe we'll start
opening up brass knuckle shops and stuff
like that I don't know if that'll
actually happen I think that's a little
ridiculous people will sell these brass
knuckles and they should be allowed to
sell them because people have a right to
defend themselves with these Knuckles if
someone gets attacked by someone with
brass knuckles representative Muse that
person will go to jail for an assault
charge I do not need you to lecture me
thank you very much well then don't do
it to us repres okay address the chair
thank you Mr chair and I apologize for
that if someone gets attacked they will
go to jail for an assault if they're in
school if they're on the street if
someone goes out and starts beating
people with brass Knuckles the police
will throw that person into prison where
they belong but if a woman who has no
way to defend herself gets attacked by a
6'4 person on the street and has the
brass knuckles to be able to defend
themselves and then as representative
Manion said that person gets laid out so
be it they shouldn't have attacked a
woman on the street and they shouldn't
have been attacking people and that
woman has a right to defend themselves
brass knuckles or as I said they could
pick up a rock from the forest if we
don't make this bill
legal very good all right um
representative
Newman I guess you don't like it I'm not
sure that this bill does what it intends
and I'm just talking about the wording
of the
bill it says um to repeal RSA 15916 is
repealed and and reenacted as
follows uh 15916 says whoever accept is
provided by law and this Amendment as I
read it says any person under under the
age of 18 who carries or person or
slungshot or mentality shall be guilty
of a violation and such weapon so
carried shall be forfeited to the state
does that since You' repealed it does
does what you've repealed it says
whoever does this now only apply to
people under 18 I'm I'm confused about
that I think so the language before made
those items illegal the language now
would say anyone under 18 who carries
these items it is illegal okay so I
think that's what that does I'll look at
the other SE thank you very much you're
welcome um with that I'm going to ask
the clerk to call the role I think we've
no pun intended beat this one to death
um representa the the um motion is ought
to
pass
huh
you yeah well I don't want to do that
going I don't want to do that to her so
I'm gonna if she's right outside
okay all right um call the r I'll have
to
pass Vice chair rhods yes can we she
wasn't yes she was I was
oh
okay Vice chair
roads representative Pratt yes
representative scitec yes representative
pu yes representative janen yes
representative Manion yes representative
Reed yes representative Lynn yes
representative tenar yes representative
Harry gther no representative muse no
representative
Balden
no representative Bradley no
representative Murphy no representative
Newman no the clerk votes yes
representative Neel yes Representative
celik no representative wheeler yay
chairman Roy chairman yes 13 to7 13 to7
um again it is not going on consent
obviously reports pleased by Tuesday and
with that I close the executive session
on whatever house bill that was what is
this 76
1276 and with that what's next
1319 1319 who are um who's
representative M be doing The Minority
Report okay um
1319 I open executive session and I
recognize representative Muse for a
[Music]
motion Mr chair I uh I move to uh uh to
move Amendment uh
2024 -
0209 and move
hb13 uh 1319 ought to
pass second on is there a second on the
motion seconded by representative
wheeler would you like to speak to your
motion represent
M what this what this amendment uh would
basically do is uh correct a one-word
typo uh in the original bill that was
pointed out by representative janver
during the public hearing um so that's
basically the story on the amendment and
I'll talk about the bill when we get to
the
bill um do you want to speak to your
second representative wheeler okay that
was pretty clearcut um I'll ask cour
call the RO on the
amendment Vice chair roads yes
representative Pratt yes representative
scitec yes representative PR yes
representative janen yes representative
Manion yes representative Reed yes
representative Lynn yes yes
representative tenar yes representative
Harry cth yes representative
Muse yes representative Bolton yes
representative Bradley yes
representative Murphy yes representative
Newman yes the clerk votes yes
representative Newell yes representative
selik yes representative wheeler yay
chairman Roy chal yes 20 20 the
Amendments adopted I recognize
representative Muse for
motion Mr chair I move HB 19 ought to
Amendment second representative wheeler
uh represent M you like to speak to your
motion what what this bill does is it
essentially um uh amends New Hampshire's
revenge porn statute uh to include uh
digitally generated synthetic images so
one of the things we've all been reading
about uh is how essentially uh uh AI is
changing uh a lot of things uh uh the
ability to do things like create deep
fake images um is something that uh is
harming not only celebrities uh but it's
harming uh people's daughters it's
harming 24 year olds who try to get a
job and find out that there's a deep
fake image of them on uh on PornHub uh
that their uh potential new employer is
actually finding when they do a Google
search of them um the bottom line is
that we make um the
the the non-consensual
dissemination of um these types of
images when they're photographs a class
B felony in New Hampshire um and the act
of taking some the the face of an
innocent person and pasting them over um
the body of another person doing
something that that the the person who
owns the face um uh wasn't a party of
and didn't do I I think is um
it's reprehensible uh and we have a lot
of work I think to do as a legislature
to try to figure out things like like AI
um and try to figure out you know what
are some of the ways that we can you
know in a common sense kind of way you
know begin to to protect people more uh
in New Hampshire than they currently are
um and I think that there will be some
work that's happening at the at the
national level at least I hope there's
some work that actually emerges from
Congress because I know people in both
parties are concerned about this um but
I think this is this is one small thing
uh that we could do uh here in New
Hampshire that would uh that would
actually uh address a situation that
we're already starting to see and and we
actually heard testimony uh from the
state police that this is something that
yes we already are starting to see this
in our
state thank you um would you like to
speak to your second represent wheeler
yes please Mr chairman really quickly um
just as a young person who is on the
internet a decent amount and sees this
it's a very it's concerning I mean the
rise and prevalence of AI and revenge
porn and fake synthetic images that are
being created
to I mean do horrible things to people I
mean and if you're a celebrity then you
have the wealth the status the power to
be able to you know solve that issue in
whatever way would be you could solve it
um prosecutorial or whatever but if
you're a regular person on the ground
you have no recourse to be able to get
somebody addressed with this and that
person can just keep making these images
and well you can't do anything about it
well now we can't class B felony and I
think that's a really good thing and I
appreciate representative abuse for
bringing this bill forward I I agree
thank you um representative Muse and I
have both been the victim of that
recently together I don't I don't think
it's been pornh Hub yet but it's it's it
has uh it has made the Browns um don't
yeah um further
discussion representative um Lynn you
know I just just to I just raise an
issue um we have in judiciary and fact
we're going to probably execute in on
March 6th um of of what I think is a
very similar Bill dealing with um um
artificial de dealing with deep fakes
and basically our bill would make
it makes a creates a felony to have it
you know to to use a deep fake it
creates a cause of action for that and
it also has a provision uh uh
prohibiting its use in in political uh
you know unless there's unless there's a
a disclosure of some kind so I'm just I
I I you know I don't I haven't looked at
your bill so I don't know whether your
bill may be better than our bill I'm
just saying I just wanted to let the
committee know that there is another and
maybe I suppose it's possible some other
committee might have you know Commerce
or something I don't know but just let
you know we we do have F I know there
are five different bills that are
dealing with this in in one way or
another um we actually have another bill
I think we're going to be executing
later today that that also kind of gets
into this
territory as I looked at it and the
reason why I decided to focus narrowly
on this is is I think that um to me this
seems to be a pretty open and shut
extension of our of our current law it
seems to be something we can get our
teeth around now with some of the other
things there are there are First
Amendment issues that are involved there
there are a lot of complexities with
trying to regulate this in the right way
um and uh so this just struck me as
something that we could do and and get
started with yeah I'd rather I'd rather
I'd rather pass them and let's sort it
out at the floor which one's best um
rather than have them all everyone
assume that someone else is doing it um
but we will will be actually um probably
deferring to you in a couple minutes on
one of the bills that we are going to
address so
um um well now we're going to have
further discussion um representative PR
because I think you want to stay longer
um now what what um so the the motion
before us now is to adopt the amendment
or did we do that we did that U motion's
ought to pass that ask cler callor
roll Vice chair roads yes representative
Pratt yes representative scitec
representative PR oh yes representative
janen for Taylor yes representative
Manion yes representative Reed yes
representative Lynn yes representative
tansar yes representative Harry gther
yes representative Muse yes
representative Balon yes representative
Bradley yes representative Murphy yes
representative Newman yes the clerk
votes yes representative Newell yes
representative sake yes representative
wheeler yes chairman Roy chair votes yes
20 20 the motion passes um any objection
to consent seeing none close the
executive session on House Bill 1319
open the executive session on House Bill
1336 recogniz representative Jamber M
motion Mr chairman I move
OTP is there second by representative um
who second did oh roads did would you
like to speak to your motion
yes thank you uh little story I used to
work for a federal agency that
um requires you not to have a firearm on
the premises and locked my firearm in
the car and parked off premises uh so it
could be able to go hunting after work I
work third shift for this agency um I
think that if we've extended the castle
doctrine to our homes and our cars uh
that our cars are pretty sanct toan
so uh the sanctity of that car um you
should be able to keep a firearm there
as long as it's locked and secure from
outside pilage I I believe that it's it
definitely is something that should be
allowed in the
state AB BR like to speak to a second
sure thank you Mr chairman
um you know basically the what
represented Jen said is what I would say
I would just add that there is some
debate and some question about well what
if somebody breaks into your car well
now you're a thief um and that's illegal
to break into my car and
um you know if I'm respecting the wish
of said business and not taking a
firearm in which they wouldn't know but
if I did respect that and I left it in
my car um I I feel like I've at least
made a happy compromise I've was able to
keep myself
protected wherever it was I was going
and then respected the wishes of said
business and didn't carry my take my
firearm in um and with that you don't
want to find a gun in my car don't break
into
it thank you um I this is what I would
say we have extended to businesses and
frankly people the right to say um you
know I respect your second amendment
rights but not in here um restaurants
are free to say you can't come in bars
are free to say you can't come in um and
if you do that you can be um rescu for
trespassing I believe so if businesses
your employer says you know what your
rights are your rights but not in our
business we respect that um but at the
same time we do not want to disarm
people of their of their second
amendment rights for the remainder of
their trip remainder of their day many
people work late and they have a long
commute home their car breaks down the
side of the road there near no firearm
we every day in the news we see stories
of someone found somewhere who
disappeared
I don't think we want that in New
Hampshire um Firearms we have a specific
crime of Lara firearm I believe which is
a felony um so if someone breaks it's
not the same as breaking into your car
and stealing your your Kenwood in your
bazooka base tube um it's stealing a a
felony is stealing a firearm so I
believe we've covered that in the law so
I think that's that's all I have to say
in that further discussion
representative Murray thank you Mr chair
um M representative Jan Ren I just
wanted to um ask you said that castle
doctrine does include your car it does
okay thank you because I just I feel
like my biggest concern with this is
just we're getting into a gray area of
property rights and personal rights and
um I don't know that makes it
OTP represent Muse
what the castle doctrine doesn't include
is your car when you drive it onto
somebody else's
property um I I think that's something
that we need to focus on a little bit
here um I know my employer for almost 30
years uh had me uh sign a non-compete
agreement I had to sign multiple
non-disclosure agreements over the years
there are a whole bunch of things that
over the years I was asked to do that
interfered with my rights and I did and
I agreed to those things because they
were a condition of
employment um we just had a bill you
know where we talked about um uh you
know a school being able to set a policy
you know to uh exclude brass knuckles if
we had a problem with brass knuckles in
schools um here we have a situation
where an employer you know for instance
a daycare center um and I raised this
during the public hearing ing uh a child
care center uh you could have somebody
who yes uh has a weapon in the car and
19 out of 20 times they remember to lock
the door but this one day their phone
went off they got a message and for one
reason or another they didn't lock the
car um if that car happens to be parked
near the kids playground there's a
chance that kids might try the door and
get in the car and you know the the the
bottom line is is this is yet another
bill that's in search for a problem um
that I don't think exists I think the
vast majority of gun owners who run into
a situation where for instance they want
to go shooting after work they're just
going to put the gun in their in the
trunk of their car anyway they're going
to stuff it under the seat or put it in
the glove compartment um I don't think
there's a law that we can pass that's
going to change that one way or the
other but I I am very concerned with the
kind of message that this that this
sends um and I'm also concerned with the
fact that you know here we are once
again flip-flopping on the issue of the
rights of property owners and you know
it just seems we kind of go back and
forth depending on which way it it seems
to suit us um so that that's essentially
the problem that I have with the
Bill thank you represent Manion thank
you Mr chair um the difference I see
here is when you sign non-disclosure
agreements or any other kind of
agreements with your employer while
you're in the
building I'm going to guess that none of
those infringe on your constitutional
rights other than this and they're and
they're infringing on your
constitutional rights when you're off
property traveling to and from so I
think that might be the difference in
this Poss representative um represent M
did you want to um address that to the
chair yeah there there is a an issue of
you know of of free speech as well um
there also you know is an ongoing issue
with things like you know in New
Hampshire and other states with
non-compete agreements which arct which
restrict can restrict your ability to
move and to you know to earn an income
so there are you know and these are
these are ESS essentially things that
we've kind of agreed to in the law to
allow employers to do their business and
one of the things that they can and I
worked in HR for an awful long time and
one of the things that they they can do
is basically hand you a code of conduct
or or essentially a rule book and and
essentially have you sign a document
that basically says you will act in
accordance with these policies and if
you do not in act in accordance with
cause represent
Pro well the difference between a
non-disclosure in the first first
amendment in this is my life is not in
jeopardy when I can't say something but
if I can't bring my protection with
me to and from
work and I get I stop at the store and
somebody tries to rob me and ends up and
I have no defense because I couldn't
bring it to work that's the
difference right and if it stays locked
in my
car it's not affecting me at
work represent Manion thank you Mr chair
uh as far as our first amendment is
concerned um that's infringement from
the the government not your employer so
it's a little bit different when I'm off
property My Second Amendment right to
carry has now been taken away by the
business but if they ask you not to
speak about something that's not the
government telling you to do that so
that doesn't apply the First Amendment
doesn't apply to
that what you mean is the First
Amendment restricts the government from
Banning your speech not your employer
your employer is free to ban whatever it
wants and you're free to seek other
employment should you so desire um
representative wheeler then
representative Balden thank you Mr
Speaker CH Mr chairman um I was told
mistruths about this in caucus I'll be
voting the way I said I was going to
vote in caucus but we'll probably change
my vote on the floor that's all I I have
no idea what you mean but okay
representative Balden
have we covered how this affects when
the federal government is an
employer because um you can't have guns
on like Postal Service property they
have a yeah that's changed I think right
but no one yeah Cas law you thought you
were on top of it but you're not no I
don't well I'll be Googling this and
raising my hand again as needed no no no
um I to to answer that question real
quick
this would have zero effect on postal
property or federal if you're federal
government your employer the federal
rules uh we cannot tell the federal
government they can't fire you because
you violated that um we we would um the
preemption um would stop that I believe
but isn't it doesn't it come become
pretty muddy at that point where maybe
someone hears about this if it passes
into law and is inv vetoed and then they
don't understand the the menu shed I
mean that's really complex ignorance of
the law is not a defense I know but
that's what I'm saying is are we setting
people up for a problem here I
personally will um put it on my my
Facebook page um representative sake
thank you uh not surprisingly I don't
really support this law but um the
bigger issue that I see is the
enforceability or lack of
enforceability um who's who's monitoring
who's
checking and so I just don't support it
because I don't see it as explain what
you mean please monitor who's monitoring
who's checking to make sure cars are
locked in the parking lot is the
employer doing that to make sure that if
you are someone they know is likely to
be carrying a gun they're going out to
check that your car is locked or not
like it just it gets to me there's too
many complications for me to feel
comfortable with it okay I I believe
though it exempts the employer from
liability um so they wouldn't feel the
need unless they were paranoid to check
your car
um I think we've pretty much dealt with
this one um the motion on the floor is
ought to pass um and I would ask clerk
rooll vice chair Roots yes
representative Pratt yes representative
scitec representative PR yes
representative jandrin yes
representative Manion yes representative
Reed yes representative Lynn yes
representative tzar yes representative
Harry cther no representative muse no
representative Balon no representative
Bradley no representative Murphy no
representative Newman no the clerk votes
no representative Newell no
wheeler no nay chairman Roy cheer votes
yes yay 10 10 10 10 the motion fails um
you can go through um another vote if
you want to or we can just leave it and
let it go to the floor with no
recommendation I don't think we have to
do it yeah I don't think
so yeah yeah okay so yeah we have no we
have no motion so it goes with no
recommendation um again on this one uh
reports I would uh representative Muse
or someone else going to take this one
for The Minority Report representative m
is going to do it uh again please
everyone um no joke Tuesday I need those
reports um let me see what do we got
excuse me Mr chair will we have a list
of who's doing the reports yeah I think
representative RH has got that and
she'll send it out thank you in the
clerk as well everyone but me um so now
we've got what are we up to what are we
up to
now I got 1344 okay thank you here I
open the executive session on House Bill
1344 and
recognize representative rhods to make a
motion thank you Mr chairman I make a
motion to itl House Bill
1344 is there a second seconded by
representative Murray representative Ro
you like to speak to your motion sure
thank you Mr chairman if anybody could
help me out with this I would gladly
take it I do not
if I'm not mistaken I don't think that
this sponsor showed up to introduce the
bill and I don't know that any of us
really remember exactly what it was
about um but my understanding is that it
is very much illegal to try to solicit
minors for sexual activity so other than
other than that I really don't know too
much about what this bill did so like I
said I'm happy to take any help I can
get it representative Murray would you
like to speak to a second
thank you Mr chair um yeah I would
reiterate What U Vice chair Road said um
the sponsor was unable to come in and um
introduce the bill none of the
co-sponsors attended and the only
testimony came from an officer who was
in the room when we questioned them
about possible implications of passing
this um it seems like everything that is
trying to outlaw is already outlawed and
um it's not clear why this is
needed um I I would say this I think it
is a great disrespect to the members of
this Committee in our time to submit a
bill not show up for to introduce the
bill and that's okay I think it's
happened I haven't got an email from
anyone I don't know if anyone else did
represent Wheeler's indicating he may
have well we did as a it was within a
bunch of emails but um representative
Perez the Republican representative
Perez did send an email to the committee
apologizing initially and then sent an
email a couple of days ago apologizing
that she wouldn't be able to be here for
that I can for that to you that's okay
oh yeah well all right
so I'm going to send an email back
saying I apologize I'm not able to pass
your bill um I I don't I just don't
understand it um so um if it was
important I would I would think that
somebody there were co-sponsors on the
bill and anyway I'm I'm wasting more
time anyone else want to discuss
represent Manion thank you Mr chair yeah
I agree that this is already in law so
there's no real reason to pass it and I
want to thank representative muray for
always having the history on this stuff
because I can't remember any of it
didto okay with that um I'll ask the
clerk to call the role the motion on
floor is in expedient to
legislate representative roads yes
representative Pratt yes representative
scitec representative pu yes
representative chanan yes representative
Manion yes representative Reed yes
representative Lynn yes representative
tenar yes representative harri gther yes
representative Muse yes representative
Balon yes representative Bradley yes
representative Murphy yes representative
Newman yes the clerk votes yes
representative Newell yes representative
sink yes representative wheeler yay
chairman Roy chair V yes 20 20 and
expedience the legislate passes any
objection to consent see none it goes on
consent hereby I close the executive
session that I ex open the executive
session session on House Bill 1
1500 and um I will make no
representative road is going to make a
motion
please thank you Mr chairman um I move
inim study for House Bill
1500 seconded by representative wheeler
would you like to speak to your motion
representative rhods sure thank you Mr
chairman um so we've heard some some
conversation about Ai
and without talking about other
legislation I have to for a second and
let it be known that representative Lynn
who will probably wish he did not come
today um actually did mention what he
mentioned earlier that there was a a
pretty in-depth bill over in the
Judiciary Committee and it was basically
discussed that instead of us trying to
piece together different pieces of
legislation to make something happen it
might be a better idea
to inim study this he can look at the
legislation that we have the legislation
that he has and hopefully come up with a
you know some good legislation around
the the concerns a lot of people are
seeming to
have thank you represent whey would you
like to speak to your second uh yes
please Mr chairman thank you I
co-sponsored this legislation alongside
representative Linda massima um you know
for the same reasons I articulated in
1319 very concerned with just the
prevalence of AI in general um and this
is more broadly the unlawful
distribution of uh misleading synthetic
media um I mean they're going to create
whole new realities with what they can
do now it's not just Photoshop or you
can tell kind of you know the wave looks
a little off so it's clearly
photoshopped no this is hyper realistic
AI generated imagery and videos that can
I mean for the lay person not even
unintelligent people but the lay person
will see that and be bought into the
narrative and then come up with a whole
opinion on something that is just
completely false and I I think we saw
that um the worries of that with what
happened in the primary election with a
robo call of you know a fake AI
President Biden come on Jack you know he
had thrown out a call and people were
convinced by that that's really
concerning you know we're talking about
these Robo calls and all this other
stuff so I would support interim study I
ultimately would hope and I know that
you had asked the speaker for this that
there would be some sort sort of
commission or something like that that
the state government could look at so
that we could come with just the general
topic of AI and how the state government
could approach that in a way that would
be meaningful and actually address
something for the uh constituents here
in the state who would be misled by the
prevalence of this new technology
creating a new paradigm in in our world
thank you that that's actually one of my
summer projects to um to look at um I
think that for too long we are playing
catch up with technology by legislating
after things are already out and I think
um you know we're concerned about images
and phone calls I'm concerned about you
know we've almost had War start already
over pictures that were not real so I
think that we really got to get a hold
of this um having said that
representative um Lynn does have a
comprehensive bill um we passed one bill
earlier now they have that one plus I
believe there's a few others I think we
have enough AI subject matter there to
work with so I go I agree with interm
study represent breed thank you Mr
chairman I I agree with the interm study
um and that something definitely needs
to be done my only concern with this
bill was that who's going to be there
was a heavy focus on on political um you
know uh points and my con my concern
with this is who's going to be the
designated Arbiter of Truth and will
this be used as a form of
censorship um if you know I think we
need to put guard rails in place um to
ensure that the truth is the truth and
not one group has um say over what is
their definition of truth that is my
concern thank you yeah I agree that's um
in any type of thing like that you have
to at the end of the day wonder who's
who's checking the true Checker
representative Manion thank you Mr chair
well while I think I could benefit from
a little bit of AI myself um I agree
with both representative wheeler and
representative
Reed represent
Jam thank you thank you Mr chairman
um in looking at my notes for this bill
uh I noticed there's I wrote down a few
notes one is that there was no intent as
an element of the crime um there was no
mention of social media companies being
liable for distribution ution um it
seemed to be slanted to regulate speech
for elections mostly um and I will note
that the Federal Communications
Commission and the Federal Election
Commission have already taken up this
subject I think it might be useful and
under interim study for whoever works on
that to look at what the Federal
Election Commission and FCC have come up
with for their regulations so that we
can probably CAU a fir in our
statute thank you um see no further I
would ask Court to call the role the
motion on floor
is um interim
study ice chair roads yes representative
Pratt yes representative scitec
representative pu yes representative
janen yes representative Manion yes
representative Reed yes representative
Lynn yes representative tanzar yes
representative Harry Gite representative
Muse yes representative Balon yes
representative Bradley yes
representative Murphy yes representative
Newman yes the clerk votes yes
representative Newell yes representative
sik yes representative wheeler yay
chairman Roy chot yes
20 20 the motion of interum study
carries um and with that I'll close the
executive
session um this will go on consent
unless you have an objection I thought
no objection it'll be on consent and
with that I open the executive session
on um what's next 1711 House Bill
1711 we can get to it we can get to it
oh yeah I see it oh okay so
17711 I'm going to I am opening if you
stand by just for a moment I need my
calendar 23rd first off just so
everybody knows they we started opening
at 9:30 and the chairman doesn't have to
call them the exact order that they're
on here he can just open them as he
wishes or not open them um okay so I'm
going to open I'm going opening I did
open house bill 1711 I'm going to recess
House Bill 11 executive session
to March
believe is that correct make sure I got
that
right March 6th at 9:30
a.m. and that's good on that date
okay and with that I'm going to open how
the executive session on House Bill
1539 and I'm going to recess House Bill
1539 until March
6th
at sometime after
9:30 and next I'm going to let's see
we're at 1528 yes I open executive
session House Bill
and we have an
amendment I would recognize
representative Murray to make a
motion thank you Mr chair I move
adoption of amendment
2024-25
H it's House Bill
1012 and the amendment is 0855
H the
1528 the bill is 1528 okay the amendment
085 say no she's
it's
0737 well everybody like got
it I need a
second okay thank that's fine take a
second while you're taking a second I
need to correct uh the record I um I
recessed House Bill
1539 to March 6th and I actually meant
to say March 88th at 9:30 so it is um
and there's you can talk to
representative wheeler about that um but
it it should be the only thing that day
so it'll be uh 9:30
sixth 1539 is the yeah 1539 is the
e8th and 1711 is the 6th
and that uh that's I'll keep Friday uh
open that'll be just the only thing so
we can get in and get out of here
however you'll see that the sixth will
fill up so um just mark your calendar is
the
6th and the eth the eth will only have
that um warning quickly of that bill and
then the 6th we will um have a full day
of work because we have a couple bills
that have been referred to us from
because the person who um well Mr
chairman I mean if everyone's going to
be upset about it here's what I can do I
can no no I'm no Perfect's be florid I I
I can call my grandmother and here's
what I can do I'm no I'm not going to
lay the grandmother I no I'll take the I
will call my grandmother and I will I
will be back on Tuesday the 5th I will
do that's fine um absolutely will my
brother's wife is uh going to be induced
on the
four so I'll be having a sub of March oh
okay so on this topic you're gonna be
gone for the whole week I don't know I
haven't actually booked my plate yet all
right um anyway uh the eth it stays
Sixth and eth and with that I
representative Murray you are back to
introducing your thank you Mr
chair chillo okay go thank you Mr chair
um so Amendment
0737 to House Bill 1528 um I made after
um we discussed this bill the first time
it changes the language to line up with
what is currently um the data that is
currently collected by the state police
um when they are on Northern border
patrol Duty um I forwarded um an
internal policy document from the state
police to all of you so you can um
double check for yourselves if you'd
like um and then it makes um basically
it just ma matches their internal
documents and then their forms that they
use um when uh documenting an encounter
at the border doesn't add anything
additional um it just ensures that the
information that they collect is sent to
uh the speaker the Senate President and
the
governor thank you um who seconded that
representative s would you like to speak
to your second yes thank you I I just
want to say I think the importance of
having data that we can all easily
access so that we can make the best
decisions for all our constituents is
really important and this is just a bill
asking for data to be provided in a way
that we can easily access it thank you
um I I I tend to uh support in the bill
because it it isn't asking for new
information it isn't asking for the
police to make opinions it isn't asking
them to do anything other than they
already doing and to get the data um
over to the people that we'd like to
have have eyes on it so I I think it's
fine um further discussion
representative
zitech um I'm not happy with the state
police policy because it says race who
determines race is it self-identified is
it determined by the uh Trooper uh maybe
there's an answer to that and I'll
listen to it but I don't like race
period I'd like country of origin
because what's I don't race I'm just not
I want country of origin
this is um information that they correct
when they make an arrest just to be
clear that yeah so um representative
Murray did you have your hand raised I
was just going to say that I I did I was
originally considering adding in country
of origin but because that doesn't match
up with what they're currently doing I
wanted to make sure that um we weren't
asking them to change all these forms
and their current methods for tracking
um the data of
encounters um for race
I'm trying to find um maybe just give me
a second but I do have a copy of the
forms they use and I can check and see
if that's something that they um assume
or ask people to
self-identify okay yeah I don't know how
I how they do that when they it's this
is an arrest form you're talking about
correct yeah yeah represented man you
can speak so unless I'm wrong here but
if if it's an arrest or something when
somebody's in custody and they don't
they self-identify I would never guess
it would be unknown if I don't know so
it would just come up as unknown and
that data would be just what it is y
okay further
discussion all right um with that the
motion is ought to pass or excuse me to
adopt the amendment and I would ask the
clerk to call the role Vice chair roads
yes representative Pratt yes
representative
citec yes representative appr yes
representative Janan on the amendment
no uh representative Manion yes
representative Reed yes representative
Lynn yes representative tzar yes
representative Harry Gite yes
representative Muse yes representative
Balton yes representative Bradley yes
representative Murphy yes representative
Newman yes the clerk votes yes
representative Newell yes representative
sing yes representative wheeler yay
chairman Roy CH yes 19 1 191 the
amendment is adopted I recognize
representative Murray to make a motion
thank you Mr chair I'd like to motion
for a to pass with
amendment seconded by representative
here gather would you like to speak to
your motion thank you Mr chair um I
think you know it's clear um from our
discussion what this bill does it just
ask the police to transfer the data that
they're already collecting to the
legislature um pretty simple bill and I
appreciate your
support representative here gther would
you like speak to a
second anyone else discussion seeing
none ask cler oh what oh i' just like to
point out the difficulty with race
because I just was I heard from somebody
who I just heard from somebody the just
the other day that was raised white as a
so thank you I I believe though that
this form and the information theyve
been collecting have they've been doing
it pretty much 50 60 70 80 years I don't
know how long they've been doing it
however long they've been arresting
people um I would have a problem if it
was asking them to do something new and
make a determination as to someone's
rights um further
discussion see none I ask skir to call
the RO the motion the floors to ought to
pass with Amendment Vice chair roads yes
representative Pratt yes representative
scitec yes representative
PR yes representative Jen no
representative Manion yes representative
Reed yes representative Lynn yes
representative tenar yes representative
Harry cther yes representative Muse yes
representative Balon yes representative
Bradley yes representative Murphy yes
representative Newman yes the clerk
votes yes representative Newell yes
representative sing yes representative
wheeler yay chairman Roy chot yes 191
191 is there an objection to consent
representative Jam yes uh representative
Jamber objects to consent it will go on
the regular calendar with that I close
the executive
session um and stand by for a second on
an amendment for the
next Mr chair while we're standing by
for that can I just quickly um take a
minute and go over these things with
representative Murray because I think a
lot of people have questions as well
just while you're doing that real fast
um yeah we're on break until 3 :30 and
then we'll take up the last bill and be
out of here a couple minutes after
that so if anybody was in here wondering
who did what or who owns what reports um
the clerk and myself are just going to
compare good God we're going to compare
our notes so if you have any questions
find
I'm opening the executive session of
House Bill
1366 and I'm um recognizing myself for a
motion to introduce an amendment can I
have a second please second second by
representative PR I'm introducing
amendment number
0118 um this amendment um it what it
does is it takes if you recall during
the testimony there was a issue of
people getting their suspension and then
serving it out when it wasn't boating
season anyway um so what this all this
does is it changes the time period the
really the key sentence is the last one
it says the period for the loss of the
person's privilege to operate a boat
shall be between Memorial Day and Labor
Day so that means if you get your right
to sus operate a boat suspended because
you were operating Reckless and
dangerously it's actually going to hurt
you because you can't operate the boat
when you would be normally operating a
boat versus being able to sit around all
winter and say haha I got suspended but
it doesn't matter
questions seconded um by who seconded
that represent PR do you want to speak
second it packs the punch
when they would be most hurt by it
during the summer so yep thank you any
further discussion representative
wheeler I just have a question Mr
chairman um and this might be because I
don't for some reason I'm missing the
notes from 118 but uh what was it before
the labor Memorial Day to Labor
Day it was um from the point of when the
court suspended the license to or what
you so you could have it in the win
exactly if you went to court Labor Day
yeah if you went to court in October for
something you did July your license is
now suspended for 60 days wer yeah no so
we've
this difference I
wrote you the holiday yeah the holidays
because those are the generally the days
people vote um you you take your boat
out um mostly on uh Memorial Day and
most people put their boats up Labor Day
um I don't yeah I don't have one so yeah
um I actually the they would I had a i
used to have a bass boat and what they
say is um the what is it the the
happiest and worst day of your life the
you get um they're very expensive uh to
maintain and in any event um any further
discussion on the bill representative
sing thank you um I I really support
this and I support the mod modifying the
timeline to being during the primary
summer months um as someone who has
nearly been run off the water uh on um
winaki on more than one
and wishing that those people didn't
still be able to drive till they learned
how to do it properly I very much
appreciate it thank you um
representative Newman I'm just
C I'm just curious about the the last
sentence it says any the unserved
suspension will be continued to the
following voting season yeah does does
does that take it back to the between Li
day yes um that would so in other words
if you got your boat your license
suspended in July and what you didn't
get the full 60 days in whatever was
left would carry over to the next after
Memorial Day right but I just didn't
know I just didn't know if it took it
back to between Le day and may I mean
it's different wording than the original
penalty I I think that I'm not sure just
wondering thank you no no it's a good
question I think that since we
delineated it by saying Memorial Day and
Labor Day it's clear that that's the
boting season the court will look at and
say representative Lynn would you agree
that to that I do I think I agree okay
thank you um representative scitec are
we talking about the bill or the
amendment well we're talking about the
amendment because it it replaces um that
part of the
bill um seeing no further questions I
ask clerk to call the role on the
amendment and the motion is to adopt the
amendment Vice chair roads yes
representative Pratt yes representative
scitec yes representative PR yes
representative jandrin yes
representative Manion yes representative
Reed yes representative Lynn yes
representative tenar yes representative
Harriet goth yes representative Muse yes
representative Balden yes representative
Bradley yes representative Murphy yes
representative Newman yes the clerk
votes yes representative Newell yes
representative sik I I representative
wheeler yay yay chairman
Roy I I don't I can't think of an AAL
response um so yes
20 okay the amendment is adopted um with
that I make a motion of V to pass with
Amendment um second somebody please
absolutely second by representative appr
um that the bill is open to discussion
anyone wish to discuss representative
scitec does anybody remember why Hines
reduced this to a violation it sure
seems like it's a Mis misdemeanor class
to me
but um I believe the amendment says
misdemeanor I believe I believe the
rationale was he didn't want it to
create a criminal record yeah but I
believe we took that back to a
misdemeanor correct with the
amendment
okay yeah it it looks like we took it
misdemeanor let's see let's make
sure
section
penalty
this there are two sections the first
section of the that was the amendment
the SEC which you've changed but the
first uh say in a careless and negligent
manner said that the lives and safety of
the public are endangered it's a
violation
uh I'm not happy with that actually Mr
chairman I remember when we were hearing
the bill that he presently it's a
misdemeanor yeah and he's and he wanted
to make the careless and negligent
operation of ation but Reckless
misdemeanor and does this accomplish
that it does okay so we don't have a
conflict I'm looking at the bill but the
what really matters is the actual
statute um because the bill just amends
the statute so the operation
of Freez by injury absence remov from
Place rival scene any person oper vessel
that is a man involved in accident shall
report if the operator is physically
mentally capable to make such a report
or fails or refuses to make the report
provided required information the owner
of the vessel involved in accident of
the owner's representative shall after
learning the accident
for so where's where's the say
misdemeanor I mean
violation think she has something can I
just CL pleas because so what he was
doing was he was amending the negligent
one in the first place and then he was
adding another section that that
differentiates between um between Ence
and Reckless operation of both so that's
why the second one is a misdemeanor so
that it's saying it's differentiating
between I got you the two okay it makes
sense then yes good I represent scitech
Mr chair I was just careless and
negligent and Reckless were the same in
my mind that the problem okay so we're
all clear all right thank you thank you
for pointing it out though I don't want
to pass something that conflicts any
further
discussion representative Lynn
I I I don't I don't wish to be a
nitpicker but I think that you do you
may have a problem in the in the in
section one it says any person who shall
operate a power boat upon any Waters of
the state in a careless or negligent
manner that's fine because that's
different than two which talks about a
reckless manner but then the second
phrase in one is or so that the lives
and safety of the public are endangered
and that is so that is the same as the
second phrase of two or so the lives of
of sa and safy of the public are
endangered so since you have an or there
on both of them I think you've
got you know you've got I mean the same
conduct could violate both s and I I
mean I suppose that means you could just
give it prosecutorial discretion the
prosecutor could charge under either one
I suppose well do isn't it
differentiated though by one is
negligent and one is reckless yeah
except that the or would say in other
words in a reckless manner that's one
thing or so that you know that's that's
the thing I see as a as a potential
problem
um I mean I supp as I said I suppose you
could you know you could say that the
prosecutor has the discretion to charge
one if it's as long as it doesn't
conflict if if it leaves prosecut
prosecutor yeah I suppose all right I
suppose that's all right represent I was
just going to say I apologize because I
don't I didn't seem to write the guy's
name down but we did have somebody who
came and spoke about um what does
anybody remember who it was who yeah
Captain SL and and he was talking about
um why these why the differentiation was
important and why it was because it's
about you know if you're intentionally
doing something or if you're if you're
doing something with unintentionally
yeah yes it was yeah Captain
walls yeah it was C Dy he's actually
retired from the Marine Patrol but he's
the legislative spokesman for them good
okay so do you know I
mean the way you could solve this is
just take the word or out of both of
them take the word in other words
operates in a in a negligent manner so
that the lives and safety and then the
second one would be operates in a in a
reckless manner so that the lives and
safety that I think that I think that
probably makes it clearer but it's not
you know I'm not as I say I'm I'm going
to vote for this I'm not looking to to
I'm just no I I don't want to pass any
just I just ra I just raise it because
it you know the way it's worded now in
each of these you have two offenses
negligence or the other or Reckless or
the other and the or the other is the
same on both of them to to your to your
point okay yeah to your to your point um
I don't want to pass a confusing I want
your your Amendment idea would make it
clear to the
judge versus this would be like well I'm
not sure which the legislative intended
right I think that yeah I mean I think
you could clear it up just by what I
what I would recommend to the committee
I think is we'll go ahead and pass it we
I'll do a floor amendment to to clear
that up and that way we can dispose of
it today uh representative sik I was
just going to wonder if we would recess
this till next Wednesday or whatever the
day is we're doing the one other Bill
and then have the corrected Amendment
for that day so we can vote on a clean
Amendment once rather than two
amendments on the floor yeah that's
actually probably a better idea because
then it's clean and we don't have to
worry about explaining this to everybody
on the floor okay so I I we're going to
we'll recess this to um March 6th 8th
8th Excuse me yes oh you want to be here
for that one yeah okay uh this this
executive session is recess to March
88th at 9:30 a.m. with the remaining
ones if that's okay the clerk is looking
at me um do I need to stop for a
second not at all yeah um before I bang
any hammers we're going to take a two
Bal
m
m Mr
chairman Mr chairman yes M represent
approve any chance we could move all the
bills that we're supposed to exact on
the sixth to the 8th so we don't have to
come in on the
6th
yes eyes are on you yes but with the
caveat that we may have to um because
there's going to be more bills W stay
late there was a bill that was referred
to us yesterday I I tried to kick them
all back into play I was playing goalie
yesterday and I went up and waved a
couple but there are some that do belong
here so if we have to um as I get them
I'll schedule them as well in the eth so
yeah um for the record all the scheduled
executive bills what were they that I
put please do you have them I want to
read it onto the record so anyone in the
public is listening 1539 okay House Bill
1539 1711 1 and 1366 are now scheduled
March 1012 is the is the boat Bill no
the parenting we're going
to the amendment oh we have the
amendment we're going to do that today
then but let's finish the boat still in
the middle of the boat thing no bo you
Recess Recess the bo only have all right
so let's do 1012 this has been one heck
of a day all right um without I reopen
the executive session on House Bill 1012
and I recognize representative Murray
that thank you Mr chair um I would like
to move adoption of amendment
H would you like to speak to your
motion um I would Mr chair thank you um
after a conversation with the committee
it seemed like there would be um more
broad support if we could limit the
scope of the bill to just make
legislative intent clear and ensure that
parents aren't being um prosecuted
unnecessarily for allowing their kids to
have some fun in the woods um without
limiting too much um judges discretion
when reviewing um potential cases of
child abuse thank you um I'll speak to
my second I think
that with representative Lyn's help
today we we took a bill that could have
been confusing um the intent was clear
and so what we ended up doing was just
going back to the intent and we're
expressing the intent to the court um
and it clearly said it's not a violation
of this section for parents to allow
children to take reasonable risks to
further their development as independent
human beings so that really gives
parents actually um broad discretion um
to to parent how they wish and it it
leaves it the standard of reasonableness
which we um have great experience with
in our jurist Prudence so um I think
it's going to be a good bill and I think
everyone who said they would will be
happy any further discussion
seeing none I'd ask the clerk to call
the role on the adoption of the
amendment Vice chair roads yes
representative Pratt yes representative
scitec yes representative PR yes
representative janen yes representative
Manion yes representative Reed yes
representative Lynn yes representative
tenar yes representative Harry gther yes
representative Muse yes representative
Balton yes representative Bradley yes
representative Murphy yes representative
Newman yes represent uh the clerk votes
yes representative Newell yes
representative sake yes representative
wheeler hey chairman Roy chair votes yes
20 20 any objection to consent see none
going to consent count what oh am I'm
just trying to get out of here would you
guys just cut me a with that the uh
amendment is adopted I would ask um um
representative Murray if she has a
motion thank you Mr chair I'd like to Mo
um ought to pass with Amendment on House
second would you like to speak to your
motion um thank you Mr chair I think um
I covered it with the amendment we want
to make sure that um parents and kids
have the ability to be free and enjoy
their lives and also that judges have
discretion to ensure kids stay
safe I agree any further discussion
seeing none I M cler call the RO motion
floor is ought to pass it
Amendment Vice chair roads yes
representative Pratt yes representative
scitec yes representative PR yes
representative janen yes representative
Manion yes representative Reed yes
representative Lynn yes representative
goite representative Muse yes
representative Bolton yes representative
Bradley yes representative
Murphy yes representative Newman yes the
clerk votes yes representative Newell
yes Representative seig no
representative wheeler yay uh chairman
Roy chair yes 191 191 uh representative
s do you object to consent there no
objection to consent uh going the
consent calendar and the bill is
adopted and with that we are done for
the day I will see you all on March
someday in March I don't mean whenever I
expect to be brought something back from
Florida hey thank you all for your hard
work today Hey listen I this is
important I want to say this we we
really really did our job today we dug
into bills we debated we expressed our
opinions nobody got hit which is great
um and some some of us may have um
expressed our emotionals too much and if
anyone was offended I apologize if not I
don't it's fine well a lot of that
credit goes to you Mr chairman so thank
you very much Lottery will get you
nowhere thank you so much for your thank
you we could not have done it without
you uh Mr chief justice
list all right just so I know if I'm
it